LAST TIME I. SENATE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. WE DO TAKE TESTIMONY HERE.
WE ALLOW SIX MINUTES OF
TESTIMONY PER SIDE. PLEASE BE
CONCISE. DON'T FEEL OBLIGATED TO
USE IT ALL. IF YOU DON'T HAVE
TO. WE PULLED TWO BILLS FROM
TODAY'S AGENDA. ITEM NUMBER 12,
AB 23, 1970. MEMBERS WILSON AND
WEBER, CALIFORNIA DIGNITY AND
PREGNANCY AND CHILDBIRTH ACT AND
ITEM NUMBER 18, AB 3218.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOOD ON FLAVORED
TOBACCO LIST. SO WE HAVE 17
BILLS TODAY, WITH TEN OF THEM
BEING ON A PROPOSED CONSENT
CALENDAR. FOR THOSE TAKING NOTE,
THE CONSENT CALENDAR CONSENTS
CONSISTS OF THE FOLLOWING ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB 1841 ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER, STUDENT SAFETY.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB 2161 ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA. THE EARLY
PSYCHOSIS INTERVENTION PLUS
PROGRAM ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
2237 ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
AGUIAR-CURRY CHILDREN AND YOUTH.
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB 20 703
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, AGUIAR-CURRY.
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTERS AND RURAL HEALTH
CLINICS. ITEM NUMBER 11, AB
2271. ASSEMBLY MEMBER ORTEGA
SAINT ROSE HOSPITAL WITH
AMENDMENTS. ITEM NUMBER 31 AB
2428 ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON
MEDI-CAL ITEM NUMBER 14, AB
2549. SO MEMBER GALLAGHER
PATIENT VISITATION WITH
AMENDMENTS. ITEM NUMBER 15, AB
2550. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL
BUSINESS ESTABLISHMENTS BUILDING
STANDARDS, ITEM NUMBER 16 AB
2599. ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND
TOXIC MATERIALS COMMITTEE.
WATER, PUBLIC BEACHES AND ITEM
NUMBER 19, AB 2859. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JIM PATTERSON, EMERGENCY
MEDICAL TECHNICIANS PEER SUPPORT
WITH AMENDMENTS. HAVING DONE
THAT, LET'S MOVE FORWARD WITH
OUR FIRST ITEM. AND OUR FIRST
ITEM IS AB 1843 ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ. EMERGENCY AMBULANCE
EMPLOYEES, PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
READY. THANK YOU, CHAIR AND
SENATORS, THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB 1843.
FIRST, I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR, FOR YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF, FOR YOUR WORK
AND ATTENTION ON THIS BILL
TODAY. I WILL ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS. THIS
BILL WOULD SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE
AND EXPAND THE MENTAL HEALTH AND
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT OPTIONS
AVAILABLE FOR OUR EMS WORKERS IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR, AMBULANCE
COMPANIES WITH OVER 35 YEARS
WORKING IN THE EMS FIELD, I KNOW
FIRSTHAND THE DIFFICULTIES OF
BEING A FIRST RESPONDER AND
ENCOUNTERING TRAUMATIC INCIDENTS
DAILY. WE ARE CONSISTENTLY,
CONSISTENTLY EXPOSED TO DEATHS,
SEVERE INJURIES AND LIFE
THREATENING CONDITIONS, ALL
WHILE WORKING LONG AND IRREGULAR
HOURS. THIS COMBINATION OF
FACTORS CREATES STRESSFUL WORK
AND HOME ENVIRONMENTS. IN 2018,
THE VOTERS APPROVED PROPOSITION
11, WHICH PROVIDED PRIVATE
EMERGENCY AMBULANCE EMPLOYEES UP
TO TEN EMPLOYER PAID MENTAL
HEALTH SESSIONS THROUGH AN
EMPLOYER ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
KNOWN AS EAP. HOWEVER THESE
RESOURCES HAVE BEEN INADEQUATE
OR DIFFICULT TO ACCESS. FOR
EXAMPLE, EMS WORKERS CANNOT
ACCESS PROVIDERS WHO SPECIALIZE
IN THEIR FIRST RESPONDER RELATED
ISSUES. AS A RESULT, THESE
WORKERS ARE OFTEN USING THEIR
LIMITED EAP SESSIONS JUST TO
FIND AN APPROPRIATE PROVIDER TO
SERVE THEIR NEEDS. ADDITIONALLY
THE AMERICAN PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION FOUND THAT 15 TO 20
SESSIONS ARE NEEDED FOR OUR
FIRST RESPONDERS TO BEGIN
RECOVERING FROM DIAGNOSED PTSD
INCURRED ON THE JOB TO RESOLVE
THESE ISSUES. THIS BILL WOULD
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF EAP
SESSIONS AND ALLOW OUR EMS
WORKERS TO BE TREATED BY
PROVIDERS FAMILIAR WITH THEIR
PARTICULAR INDUSTRY AND ITS
CHALLENGES. PRIVATE AMBULANCE
EMPLOYEES FACE CHALLENGES IN
SCHEDULING APPOINTMENTS WITH
PROVIDERS IN A TIMELY MANNER.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
APPOINTMENTS TO BE SCHEDULED
WITHIN 48 HOURS UPON REQUEST,
ENSURING PRIVATE AMBULANCE
EMPLOYEES RECEIVE TIMELY CARE.
AB 1843 WOULD ALSO REQUIRE PEER
TO PEER SUPPORT SERVICES TO BE
AVAILABLE FOR PRIVATE AMBULANCE
EMPLOYEES. UNFORTUNATELY, A 2016
SURVEY BY THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF EMTS FOUND THAT
ONLY 28% OF AGENCIES NATIONWIDE
ADOPTED PEER SUPPORT PROGRAMS,
WITH AB 1843. OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS WILL HAVE THE
RESOURCES AND SUPPORT THEY NEED
TO ADDRESS THE MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS AND RECOVER SO THAT WAY
THEY CAN CONTINUE PROVIDING
CALIFORNIANS WITH EMERGENCY CARE
THEY NEED AND DESERVE. WITH ME
TODAY TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY IS
AMBER STOVER FROM SACRAMENTO,
REPRESENTING UNITED
STEELWORKERS. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR ROTH AND
HEALTH COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS AMBER STOLLER AND I AM A
15 YEAR EMT OF LOCAL 12, NINE,
11 AND A STAFF REP WITH UMW IN
CENTRAL VALLEY. I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY ON BEHALF OF MY LOCAL
MEMBERS AND OUR SIBLINGS OF US
LOCAL 1853. IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. EVERY DAY OUR
MEMBERS LEAVE FOR WORK, NOT
KNOWING WHAT TYPE OF SITUATION
WILL BE ENCOUNTERED THAT DAY.
THE ONE THING WE DO KNOW IS THAT
THE DEDICATION AND CARE WE
PROVIDE WITHIN MULTIPLE
COMMUNITIES CAN MEAN THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LIFE AND
DEATH. AS FIRST RESPONDERS, IT
IS OUR PRIVILEGE TO SERVE OUR
PATIENTS WITH THE BEST POSSIBLE
CARE. UNFORTUNATELY, THE CARE
THAT MAY BE NEEDED TO US IS NOT
GIVEN THE SAME CONSIDERATION NOR
COMMITMENT. IT AND IS THIS
REASON I AM HERE TODAY TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB 1843, TO ENSURE
THAT ACCESS AND FOLLOW THROUGH,
TO RECEIVE MENTAL HEALTH CARE
AND EFFECTIVE EAP PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATION RESPONSIBILITY IS
ACHIEVED. AB 1843 PROVIDES A
CRITICAL PATHWAY TO THESE MUCH
NEEDED SERVICES. CURRENTLY WE
HAVE MEMBERS WHO HAVE, AFTER
MONTHS OF FOLLOW UP, UNABLE TO
GET AN APPOINTMENT OR RECEIVE
ANY ÁP ASSISTANCE. REPEATEDLY.
THEY HAVE BEEN TOLD BY
FACILITATORS THERE ISN'T ANYONE
AVAILABLE TO SEE THEM AND TO
FOLLOW UP MONTHLY ON THEIR OWN,
TO NO AVAIL. IT DEFEATS THE
PURPOSE OF AN EAP IF THE MENTAL
HEALTH CARE NEEDED ISN'T THERE
FOR MONTHS ON END OR AT ALL.
WHILE PERFORMING A JOB THAT
DAILY PLACES THE WORKERS
DIRECTLY INTO VOLATILE AND
DANGEROUS SITUATIONS, THE PTSD
EFFECTS AND IMPACTS ARE VERY
REAL. AS IS THE CARE NEEDED THAT
CARE SHOULD NOT, THAT CARE
SHOULD AND MUST BE PROVIDED BY
SOMEONE WHO HAS EXPERIENCE AND
TRAINING IN TRAUMA COUNSELING.
RESPONDING TO CRITICAL INCIDENTS
IS WHAT WE DO EACH DAY, PUTTING
OURSELVES AT RISK WITHOUT ANY
THOUGHT OTHER THAN SAVING LIVES.
TODAY WE ASK YOU TO SUPPORT AB
1843 TO ENSURE OUR MEMBERS CAN
HAVE ACCESS TO WHAT THEY NEED TO
POTENTIALLY SAVE THEIR LIVES
WHEN EXPERIENCING THEIR MOST
DIFFICULT CHALLENGES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON BEHALF OF ALL FIRST
RESPONDERS WHO NEED THIS FOR
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH AND
WELL-BEING. THANK YOU TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ FOR
AUTHORING THIS CRITICAL BILL AND
I THANK YOU, CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU, MA'AM. THANKS FOR
JOINING US. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE? GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. JANICE
O'MALLEY FROM AFSCME CALIFORNIA.
ALSO, ON BEHALF OF OUR UNITED
EMS WORKERS, LOCAL 4911 HERE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEGAN
SUPERS, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD TO SEE YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? OKAY OKAY.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS MEASURE?
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF FOR THE
RECORD. AND YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY. SIR BUT FIRST I'LL TURN
OFF MY MIC. IT'S ALWAYS A GOOD
THING. GOOD AFTERNOON. I'M SEAN
HENSCHEL HERE. ON BEHALF OF
AMERICAN MEDICAL RESPONSE.
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST PROVIDER OF
EMERGENCY AMBULANCE SERVICES.
AMR IS RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO
AB 1843. AS IS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN, THE PROBLEMS OF MENTAL
HEALTH AND INHERENT STRESS
ASSOCIATED WITH EMS ARE NOT IN
DISPUTE TODAY. REGRETTABLY, THE
EAP LANGUAGE PROPOSED TODAY DOES
NOT SOLVE THE PROBLEM. THIS
COMES DOWN TO WHAT IS THE
PURPOSE OF THE PROGRAM. EAP IS
INTENDED TO SERVE IMMEDIATE AND
SHORT TERM ISSUES AND TO TRIAGE
REFERRALS WHEN APPROPRIATE, TO
SPECIALIZED LONG TERM CARE.
CALIFORNIA'S OAN HR BENEFITS
WEBSITE STATES THE SAME SHORT
TERM AND REFERRAL. OUR DATA
AROUND CURRENT UTILIZATION OF
EAP IS BELOW 3, AND OF THAT 3,
THE EMPLOYEES THAT USE EAP
SERVICES, THE AVERAGE
UTILIZATION IS 4.5 VISITS. THE
LOW VISIT, THE LOW VISIT
UTILIZATION DEMONSTRATES THAT
THE EMPLOYEES ARE BEING REFERRED
TO LONG TERM TREATMENT BEFORE
MAXING OUT ON EAP SESSIONS. PTSD
AND OTHER SERIOUS MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES DO NOT SIMPLY GO AWAY
AFTER 20 VISITS, THEY CAN
REQUIRE YEARS OF LONG TERM
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT.
CORRECTLY POINTED OUT BY THE
AUTHOR, THIS LONG TERM COVERAGE
IS BEING PROVIDED UNDER EXISTING
HEALTH INSURANCE, AS IS REQUIRED
UNDER PROPOSITION 11. AGAIN, EAP
IS NOT INTENDED TO ADDRESS LONG
TERM MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS. AFTER
20 VISITS, THE PROVIDER OR
PATIENT RELATIONSHIP THAT'S BEEN
ESTABLISHED OVER A FEW WEEKS OR
MONTHS IS SEVERED ABRUPTLY AND
CAUSING UNFAIR HARM TO THE
PATIENT. PROPOSITION 11 WAS
CAREFULLY WRITTEN TO REQUIRE
MENTAL HEALTH COVERAGE,
EDUCATION AND INCREASED EAP
ACCESS, WHICH IS BETTER THAN THE
COVERAGE REQUIRED FOR PUBLIC EMS
EMPLOYEES. THE COST OF INCREASED
EAP IS NOT THE CONCERN, BUT
SPENDING MORE AND GETTING
NOTHING IN RETURN THAT ADDRESSES
THE. THE ISSUE IS A PROBLEM.
WHAT WE NEED IS FOR HEALTH
INSURERS TO PAY REASONABLE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES TO MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS TO ENSURE
LONG TERM ACCESS. WHAT WE NEED
IS MORE MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS THAT SPECIALIZE IN
EMS ISSUES. THE PROVIDER
SHORTAGE IS VERY CORRECTLY NOTED
IN THE POLICY COMMENT WITHIN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. THANK YOU
FOR THAT. IN CLOSE AMR'S
OPPOSITION IS NOT ABOUT A COST
ISSUE, BUT SIMPLY THAT IF AN
INCREASED BENEFIT IS GOING TO BE
FUNDED BY THE EMPLOYER, IT
SHOULD ACTUALLY HELP TO ADDRESS
THE PROBLEM. AMR RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTS A NO VOTE AT THIS TIME,
AND WELCOMES ANY DIALOG FROM THE
AUTHOR OR THIS COMMITTEE AROUND
ADDRESSING INCREASING ACCESS TO
PROVIDERS. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE?
NAME, POSITION AND AFFILIATION
ONLY. PLEASE GOOD AFTERNOON,
JARED MOSBY. AFTER 911 AMBULANCE
ALLIANCE IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER OPPOSITION
WITNESSES SEEING NONE. LET'S
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
DAIS. AND MY COLLEAGUES,
COLLEAGUES, ANY QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS? SENATOR
MENGIBAR, ASSEMBLY MEMBER, CAN
YOU, DO YOU HAVE ANY RESPONSE TO
THE FACT THAT ONLY APPROXIMATELY
3, OF EMPLOYEES ARE UTILIZING
THE ALREADY TEN AFFORDED
SERVICES OR SESSIONS, OR FOR
ONE, IT'S A VERY SMALL
UTILIZATION. ONLY TEN. AND IT
TAKES TIME TO FIND THAT RIGHT
PROVIDER. RIGHT. AND SOMETIMES
YOU CAN'T EVEN FIND IT IN TEN.
YOU NEED MORE. SO ONCE AGAIN,
IT'S JUST ALLOWING TEN MORE.
SORRY, SORRY. SOMETIMES YOU
CAN'T FIND IT IN TEN. WHAT IN
TEN VISITS? TO FIND THE RIGHT
PERSON THAT CAN HELP YOU WITH
YOUR ISSUE. SO MY WHOLE POINT IS
JUST EXTEND. I WOULD PUSH BACK
ON THAT. OKAY I DON'T THINK IT
TAKES TEN VISITS TO FIND IF THAT
THERAPIST WORKS FOR YOU AS A
THERAPIST MYSELF, OR AS SOMEONE
WHO OBSERVED, OBTAINING THERAPY,
YOU DON'T WAIT TEN SESSIONS. IN
TEN SESSIONS, THAT MEANS IT'S
GOING REALLY WELL. YOU SEVER THE
RELATIONSHIP IF IT'S NOT GOING
WELL AFTER 1 OR 2 SESSIONS.
THREE MAX. MIKE. SO IF ONLY 3%
OF EMPLOYEES ARE UTILIZING NOW,
WHY DO WE NEED TO INCREASE IT?
WELL, ONCE AGAIN, THIS IS A VERY
UNIQUE SITUATION, RIGHT? AND
PRIVATE SECTOR EMS, AS YOU KNOW,
YOU WORKED IN THAT INDUSTRY.
IT'S VERY HARD TO FIND PEOPLE
THAT CAN RELATE TO YOUR TYPE OF
JOB. YOU DO RIGHT. IT'S VERY
DIFFERENT THAN ANY OTHER TYPE OF
OCCUPATION, SO TO SPEAK. SO ONCE
AGAIN, JUST TO ME, ALLOWING TEN
MORE EXTRA SESSIONS IN CASE IT'S
NEEDED. RIGHT. BECAUSE SOMETIMES
NOT EVERYBODY IS GOING TO BE
THERE. THEIR PROBLEM IS GOING TO
RESOLVE WITHIN TEN SESSIONS. SO
WHY NOT JUST TEN MORE AS THEY
ALREADY TALK ABOUT IT TAKES UP
TO 20 SESSIONS TO RELIEVE YOUR
ISSUE, RIGHT? WHATEVER. I MEAN,
IT'S GOING TO BE ON A CASE BY
CASE BASIS, RIGHT? DATA CAN SAY
ONE THING, BUT THAT'S NOT THE
WHOLE PICTURE BECAUSE
EVERYBODY'S DIFFERENT, RIGHT? IF
WE LOOK FOR THERAPISTS, JUST
DEPENDING ON IF THEY HAD SIMILAR
EXPERIENCES AND US, THEN NOBODY
WOULD BE ABLE TO FIND A
THERAPIST. WE LOOK FOR
THERAPISTS WHO HAVE BACKGROUND
IN CBT, COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL
THERAPY, WHO ARE TRAUMA
INFORMED, WHO KNOW ABOUT, WHO
CAN PROVIDE PSYCHOEDUCATION. SO
I WOULDN'T SAY THAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR THERAPISTS
SPECIFICALLY WHO HAVE THEY
THEMSELVES SEEN EMERGENCIES AND
SO FORTH. AND I'M NOT HERE TO
SAY THIS POPULATION DOES NOT
NEED ALL THE LOVE AND SUPPORT
THAT THEY NEED, BECAUSE THEY DO,
AND THEY ARE OUR HIGHER LEVEL OF
EXPERIENCING THESE KIND OF CASES
. BUT I'M A DATA DRIVEN PERSON.
IF THE DATA SAYS THAT ONLY 3%
ARE UTILIZING IT, I GUESS I'M
NOT CONVINCED THAT WE NEED TO
INCREASE IT. AND I'M NOT HEARING
ANYTHING FROM YOU, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, AS TO WHY WE NEED TO
INCREASE IT. IF IT'S NOT FULLY
BEING UTILIZED. WELL, ONCE AGAIN
, I MEAN, WE CAN GO BACK AND
FORTH THERE ALL DAY AND MY THING
IS THAT'S JUST THAT PART OF THE
DATA. BUT SOMETIMES IT'S HARD
FOR SOME OTHER FOLKS THAT MAY
NEED THAT MORE TIME. RIGHT. IS
THERE SOMETHING IN YOUR BILL
THAT'S THAT WILL HELP US CAPTURE
MORE DATA? AND IF. WELL, THIS
ISN'T REALLY A DATA DRIVEN BILL,
JUST MORE ABOUT ALLOWING TEN
EXTRA SESSIONS. HOW WILL WE KNOW
THIS IS SUCCESSFUL IF WE ALLOW
TEN MORE? WELL, LET'S PUT IT IN
A PLACE. LET'S PASS THE
LEGISLATION AND SEE IF IT WORKS.
RIGHT NOW THERE'S NOTHING WE CAN
DO BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE
EXTRA 20, EXTRA TEN. I'D LIKE
ANOTHER QUESTION FOR QUESTION
FOR THE OPPOSITION. IF THIS IS
OR MAYBE EXPLAINED FOR MY
PERSONAL KNOWLEDGE, IF WE
INCREASE IT TO TEN MORE AND IT'S
20 AND IT'S THE LOW UTILIZATION
THÀNH, WHAT THEN IS THE PROBLEM
IF THE EMPLOYEES WON'T EVEN USE
THE REST? THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION. THROUGH THE CHAIR,
IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE ARE NOT PROVIDERS OF EAP
THAT ARE WILLING TO OFFER THAT
MANY SESSIONS. WHAT WOULD END UP
BEING IS THE EMPLOYER WOULD END
UP BEING THE INSURER, WHICH
THERE'S BEEN SIGNIFICANT,
SIGNIFICANT PUSHBACK FROM
EMPLOYEES THAT THEY WOULD NOT
WANT THEIR EMPLOYER TO BE THE
INSURER SIMPLY BECAUSE 20 IS NOT
OFFERED THE SLIPPERY SLOPE
ARGUMENT OF GOING FROM 20 TO 30
TO 50 OF JUST IN CASE THERE'S
SOMEBODY THAT MIGHT NEED IT.
YOUR POINT IS VERY WELL TAKEN AS
FAR AS DATA UTILIZATION IS NOT
THERE, THERE'S ONLY FOUR AND A
HALF VISITS PER SESSION, PER
YEAR, PER ISSUE, AND IT
CONTINUES TO RESET. SO OUR
CONFUSION IS REALLY NOT WHETHER
OR NOT TREATMENT SHOULD BE HAD.
IT'S WHERE IT SHOULD BE HAD. AND
OUR ARGUMENT WOULD BE UNDER
EXISTING LONG TERM HEALTH CARE.
AND THANK YOU MAYBE FOR OR
EITHER OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARE YOU CAN YOU HELP ME WALK
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF THE
REFERRALS. SO THEY'RE AFFORDED
TEN THROUGH THE I'M BUTCHERING
THE ACRONYM Â ÁP, THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO BE TRANSFERRED OUT,
REFERRED ELSEWHERE FOR LONGER
TERM AND THEY THROUGH THAT
PROVIDER CAN ALWAYS REQUEST MORE
AND MORE SESSIONS THROUGH THEIR
PROVIDER IS THE ROOT OF THE
PROBLEM HERE THAT OUR PERSONNEL,
OUR FIRST RESPONDERS, ARE NOT
GETTING ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH.
WELL, I THINK FOR ONE ONE GROUP,
IF YOU WANT TO BRING IT TO THAT
LEVEL, I DON'T THINK A PART TIME
EMPLOYEE IS OFFERED THESE
BENEFITS AND THEY SHOULD AS
WELL. CORRECT. SO IF YOU WANT TO
LOOK ABOUT NOT EVERYBODY. SO
THAT IS A GROUP OF EMPLOYEES IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR AT UMASS THAT
ARE NOT COVERED BY EAP. BUT WITH
THIS BILL, WE WANT TO TRY TO
COVER THAT AS WELL. BUT SINCE
ONCE AGAIN, GOING BACK TO THE
TEN VISITS, SINCE IT'S A VERY
SMALL AMOUNT TO SOME EMPLOYEES.
SO I FIGURED I'M ONLY GOING TO
GET TEN VISITS AND IT MAY NOT,
I'M GOING TO NEED MORE. SO I
THINK WHEN SOME FOLKS IT'S WHY
EVEN BOTHER WITH IT. THAT'S WHY
YOU SEE THE LOW DATA THAT 3,
RIGHT? IF WE HAVE ALLOWED A
LITTLE BIT MORE TIME, I THINK
YOU WILL SEE MORE FOLKS
ACCESSING IT. BUT BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT THERE YET. SO HOW CAN YOU
REALLY GET THAT CAPTURE OTHER
DATA LIKE YOU'RE REFERRING TO?
BUT THEY CAN ALWAYS ALWAYS BUT
BUT THEY CAN REFERRED. THEY CAN
BE REFERRED. EVEN IF I SAY, HEY,
I ONLY GET TEN SESSIONS, BUT IN
THOSE TEN SESSIONS THEY CAN
REFER ME ELSEWHERE FOR LONG
TERM, I DON'T KNOW IF, SOMEBODY
CAN. I CAN'T TELL YOU FOR SURE.
I DON'T WANT TO TELL YOU FALSE
INFORMATION. I AGREE WITH YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. PART TIME
MEMBERS SHOULD GET. AND I DON'T
THINK I WOULD HAVE ANY OF THESE
QUESTIONS IF THE BILL IN FRONT
OF ME SAID, HEY, WE WANT TO
OFFER PART TIME EMPLOYEES THE
SAME THE SAME BENEFITS THAT FULL
TIME EMPLOYEES HAVE IN RELATION
TO MENTAL HEALTH. I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHERE YOU GOT THIS.
NUMBER 20 SEEMS TO BE ARBITRARY.
WELL, IT'S PART OF I THINK,
MAYBE I MISSED IT IN YOUR
OPENING. I DID MISS IT IN YOUR
OPENING. WELL, IF WE TALK ABOUT
50, 50% OF PATIENTS BEGIN
RECOVERY FROM FROM PTSD, WITH
SOME PATIENTS REQUIRING MORE
THAN 20 SESSIONS TO ACHIEVE
THAT. SO THERE'S SOME
INFORMATION REGARDING THAT. THE
TEN IS NOT ENOUGH. SO IT'S
COMING BACK FROM OTHER DATA THAT
WE FOUND OUT THAT 10TH MAY NOT
BE ENOUGH FOR SOME FOLKS. RIGHT.
AND AS AS FAR AS YOU KNOW, I
MEAN, IF WE LOOK ABOUT IT, WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PRIVATE SECTOR EMS
WORKERS, RIGHT? THAT DEAL WITH
SO MANY TRAGEDIES DAY IN AND DAY
OUT. SO WHY NOT JUST OFFER THEM,
A LITTLE BIT MORE BENEFITS WHEN
IT COMES TO MENTAL HEALTH? AS WE
KNOW, IT'S REALLY BIG NOW MORE
THAN EVER. SO SO I'M JUST
THINKING THAT LET'S JUST GIVE
THEM MORE TIME IF NEEDED. AND SO
THAT WAY THEY DON'T SAY, WELL,
I'M GOING TO HAVE TEN ANYWAY.
BUT IF WE CAN EXTEND IT TO 20,
MAYBE HAVE A BETTER CHANCE OF
GETTING MY ISSUE TAKEN CARE OF.
RIGHT. AND THE FACT THAT ONCE
AGAIN, PART TIME EMPLOYEES
AREN'T ALLOWED SOME OF THESE
BENEFITS. SO LET'S LOOK AT THE
BIGGER PICTURE TOO, RIGHT? I I
GET THE PART TIME. I GUESS I'M
STILL JUST, YOU KNOW, AND IT MAY
BE ODD COMING FROM A SOCIAL
WORKER. RIGHT? I'M ALWAYS I'M
ALL FOR MENTAL HEALTH. BUT I
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE LIKE IT'S
DATA DRIVEN. AND IT SOUNDS LIKE
THEY CAN ALWAYS BE REFERRED AND
THEY CAN GET ENDLESS AMOUNT OF
THERAPY SESSIONS, THROUGH THEIR
DIRECT PROVIDER. THAT'S SO I
DON'T SEE THE GAP. I ONLY SEE
THE GAP FOR PART TIME. SO MY, MY
POINT IS, WELL, IS IF THE IF THE
OPPOSITION HAS ISSUES WITH THE
TEN, WHY NOT JUST GIVE THEM TEN
MORE? WHAT'S SO BIG WITH
ALLOWING TEN MORE VISITS? MAYBE
NOT EVERYBODY'S GOING TO USE IT
RIGHT? BUT THERE MAY BE SOME
THAT ARE BECAUSE EVERYBODY'S
DIFFERENT, RIGHT? EVERYBODY
RESPONDS TO THERAPY AND
TREATMENT DIFFERENTLY THAN ONE
ANOTHER. YOU JUST CAN'T SAY
THAT. WELL, ON AVERAGE, BUT
THERE'S OTHER FOLKS THAT MAY NOT
CAPTURE. WE'RE NOT CAPTURING
THAT THAT NEED THAT EXTRA TEN.
SO DO YOU HAVE A RESPONSE. AND
THIS WILL BE MY LAST QUESTION. I
ASKED THAT QUESTION TO THE
OPPOSITION BECAUSE I DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND EITHER. IF NOT
EVERYONE'S USING IT, WHAT'S THE
WHAT'S WHY CAN'T WE JUST OFFER
MORE THEN? AND HE SHARED THAT
THERE ARE GAPS THAT SINCE THEY
DON'T OFFER 20, THEY CAN'T FIND
PROVIDERS TO DO THIS, THAT THEN
THEY THEMSELVES WILL BECOME THE
INSURER. DO YOU THINK THAT'S THE
CASE? WELL, EVERYBODY'S GOING TO
HAVE THEIR DIFFERENCE OF
OPINION, RIGHT? I'M JUST TRYING
TO ALLOW THAT EXTRA FLEXIBILITY.
RIGHT. AS FAR AS THAT, I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING OPINION THAT
EPS WILL NOT PROVIDE 20 AND SO I
WOULD HOPE NOT. I WISH THEY
WOULD. I HOPE THEY WOULD KNOW IN
YOUR PROCESS THROUGH THIS
LEGISLATION, HAVE YOU HAD
CONVERSATIONS THAT THERE ARE EAP
PROVIDERS THAT ARE GOING TO
OFFER 20 SESSIONS? I BELIEVE SO,
BUT I CAN'T TELL YOU FOR SURE.
OKAY. THANK YOU. SENATOR, LET ME
LISTEN. I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE
MEASURE. THE BILL HAS MORE IN IT
THAN JUST THIS 2010 BUSINESS.
BUT I'M FASCINATED BY THE
QUESTION, AND I'M NOT SURE WE
GOT THE ANSWER. IF THERE'S A LOW
UTILIZATION RATE AT THE EMPLOYER
. WELL, LET ME GO BACK TO THE
BASICS. AN EMPLOYER ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM IS A PROGRAM SET UP BY
THE EMPLOYER TO PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO EMPLOYEES. SO THE
EMPLOYER THEN I ASSUME CONTRACTS
WITH PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE THE
ASSISTANCE TO EMPLOYEES. RIGHT?
THAT'S EXACTLY CORRECT, SIR.
OKAY. SO IF YOU HAVE A LOW
UTILIZATION RATE ON A PROGRAM
THAT CURRENTLY PROVIDES TEN, WE
CAN HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT
WHY INCREASE IT FROM 10 TO 20,
BUT WHY IS THERE A PROBLEM IF WE
INCREASE IT FROM 10 TO 20, IF
THERE'S A LOW UTILIZATION RATE
AT TEN? THAT WAS THE QUESTION, I
THINK, THAT MY COLLEAGUE ASKED,
AND I DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THE
ANSWER. SO I'M GOING TO ASK YOU
TO SORT OF REFRAME IT. SO THE
SIMPLETON THAT I AM CAN FIGURE
THIS OUT, I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDE
SOME CLARITY, AGAIN, AS THE
PROPONENT OF PROP 11 FROM 2018,
I CAN SPEAK TO A LITTLE BIT OF A
HISTORICAL BACKGROUND ON THIS,
WE ACTUALLY RESEARCHED WHEN WE
WERE CRAFTING THE PROPOSITION ON
THE IDEA OF EVEN DOING 40, AND
WE FOUND THAT THERE WASN'T A
PROVIDER TO BE ABLE TO OFFER
THAT. EXCUSE ME, EXCUSE ME.
THERE WASN'T A WHAT? THERE WAS
NOT A PROVIDER ON OFFERING A
PROGRAM COVERING 40 SESSIONS FOR
EAP. WELL, THAT'S A DIFFERENT
ISSUE. SURE. YOU MIGHT HAVE TO
GET TWO PROVIDERS FOR RIGHT. NOT
THE THERAPIST. HE MEANS A
COMPANY. THAT'S. NO, I
UNDERSTAND YOU MAY HAVE TO
CONTRACT WITH TWO COMPANIES.
THAT'S NOT MY UNDERSTANDING. I
WOULD DEFER TO AN EXPERT IN THE
MENTAL HEALTH FIELD ON ON HOW
MANY DIFFERENT PROVIDERS YOU
NEED TO GET MULTIPLE THINGS. BUT
MY UNDERSTANDING WAS THAT
PROPOSITION 11, EVEN IF YOU DO
TWO PROVIDERS, THAT'S TWO
DIFFERENT THERAPISTS. SO YOU
WOULD HAVE TO CUT THERAPY RIGHT
IN THE MIDDLE OF SESSIONS AND
THEN GO TO ANOTHER PROVIDER THAT
FOR THE HARMS THAT THE CLIENT
POINT VERY WELL TAKEN. YEAH
LISTEN YOU CAN I DON'T
UNDERSTAND IF THE COMPANY IF YOU
GET ONE COMPANY THAT PROVIDES A
CERTAIN BENEFIT, BUT YOUR
OBLIGATION TO YOUR EMPLOYEES IS
FOR DOUBLE THAT BENEFIT AND THEY
CAN ONLY GIVE YOU TWO, WHAT
PREVENTS THE COMPANY FROM
CONTRACTING WITH TWO PROVIDERS
TO PROVIDE THE FULL SCOPE OF
BENEFITS THAT YOU WANT TO
PROVIDE? I WAS NOT THE ONE THAT
WAS DOING THE BUSINESS OF, YOU
KNOW, TRYING TO FIND THIS
PROGRAM. I MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
IT WAS TOLD, WAS THAT IT WAS NOT
AVAILABLE OFFER, SO THE
UTILIZATION WAS LOW BECAUSE
THERE WASN'T A GREAT ENOUGH NEED
AND PEOPLE BEING PROPERLY
REFERRED TO LONG TERM CARE. THE
MARKET ISSUE. YES, IT IS THE
MARKET FOR MORE THAN TEN AND IN
THIS CASE UP TO 20. WE COULD NOT
FIND IT WAS NOT AVAILABLE. IT
MIGHT BE AVAILABLE IN THE
MARKETPLACE ELSEWHERE, BUT THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT I WAS GIVEN
FROM THE CLIENT WAS THAT IT WAS
NOT AN AVAILABLE PROGRAM. WELL,
SO THE REMEDY DID ANYBODY
SUGGEST AN AMENDMENT TO THIS
BILL TO INCLUDE THE PHRASE, TO
THE EXTENT THAT EAP PROGRAMS ARE
AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICE, I WOULD BE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO TAKE THAT AMENDMENT
SUGGESTION BACK TO MY CLIENT.
WELL, YOU'LL HAVE TO DISCUSS IT
WITH THE AUTHOR. AND THEN THE
OTHER ISSUE IS YOU USE THE TERM
SELF-INSURE. HOW DOES THE
EMPLOYER SELF-INSURE FOR EAP
BENEFITS? UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT, I DO NOT WANT TO
SPEAK OUT OF TURN ON THAT POINT.
MY UNDERSTANDING IT'S ALL
SELF-INSURED BECAUSE THE
EMPLOYER IS PAYING FOR IT,
RIGHT? IT IS REFERRED OUT, AS
FAR AS, PAYING FOR IT AT A BASE
LEVEL. BUT WHO THE INSURER IS,
IS, IS, GETS TO BE A COMPLICATED
ISSUE IS WHAT I WAS TOLD, ON
WHETHER OR NOT A SECONDARY
PROVIDER WOULD BE ABLE TO COVER
20 UNITS OR 20 VISITS AT THAT
POINT, WOULD AMR OR ANY EMPLOYER
THAT WAS SUBJECT TO THIS LAW,
HAVE TO PAY OUT OF POCKET
THEMSELVES FOR THE FULL COVERAGE
OF 20, WHETHER OR NOT IT GETS
USED? SO ARE YOU SAYING THEN IF
YOU ONCE YOU HIT THE TEN, IF
YOUR OBLIGATION IS 20 AND THE
EAP PROVIDER THAT YOU'VE
CONTRACTED WITH WILL ONLY AGREE
TO PROVIDE TEN SESSIONS PER THE
FOR THE CONTRACT PRICE, THAT THE
EMPLOYER WOULD THEN NEED TO PAY
OUT OF THE EMPLOYER'S GENERAL
FUND FOR THE ADDITIONAL TEN
SESSIONS, SEPARATE AND APART
FROM THE EAP CONTRACT. I BELIEVE
THAT IS WHAT CASE WOULD BE WITH
THE PROVIDER, WITH THE
THERAPIST. THAT'S PROVIDING THE
SERVICE? YES, BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
AS MY THE BRAINS OF THE
OPERATION POINTED OUT, WE DO
TALK ABOUT CONTINUITY OF CARE.
YES. OF COURSE. SO THE THERAPY,
THE SAME THERAPIST WOULD BE
PROVIDING THE SERVICE. I CAN'T
SPEAK TO THAT. I'M NOT IN THAT
SPACE. WELL, I WOULD DEFER TO
YOU CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHOR
IF WE WHEN WE GET FINISHED HERE.
THANK YOU. YEAH. SENATOR
MENGIBAR, DID THAT HELP ADDRESS
YOUR QUESTION? OKAY. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS, COLLEAGUES?
OKAY. I GUESS SOME OF YOU
REMEMBER, YOU MAY CLOSE ONCE
AGAIN. I'LL JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. APPRECIATE IT. WHEN WE GET
A QUORUM. THANK YOU BOTH FOR
BEING HERE. SORRY TO GRILL YOU,
SIR. GOOD. OF COURSE. ANYTIME,
SIR. THANK YOU. WHEN WE GET A
QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE A MOTION AND
WE WILL TAKE A VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, BOTH OF YOU. WHOSE
NUMBER? ÁP, ITEM NUMBER FOUR, AB
2075. DO WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALVAREZ HERE, SIR. RESIDENT
ACCESS PROTECTION ACT, PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, I'M HERE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 2075. THE
RESIDENT ACCESS PROTECTION ACT.
I WANT TO START BY THANKING THE
CHAIR AND THE STAFF OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL AND I WANT TO LET YOU
KNOW WE WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2075 IS A BIPARTISAN BILL
THAT WOULD PROVIDE RESIDENTS OF
LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES WITH
THE RIGHT TO IN-PERSON, ON SITE
ACCESS TO VISITORS DURING PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCIES AS LONG AS
THEY FOLLOW THE SAME SAFETY
PROTOCOLS AS AS THE STAFF AT THE
FACILITIES. I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THE LAST POINT VISITOR
VISITATION IS ONLY ALLOWED IF
THE VISITOR FOLLOWS THE SAME
SAFETY PROTOCOLS AS THE STAFF AT
THE FACILITY. ASSEMBLY BILL 2075
IS THE RESULT OF A WORKING GROUP
ESTABLISHED DURING THE PANDEMIC
WHO WAS TASKED WITH DEVELOPING
RECOMMENDATIONS REGARDING BEST
VISITATION PRACTICES AND
POLICIES FOR LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES DURING PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCIES. THE WORKING GROUP
MET FIVE TIMES OVER THE COURSE
OF SIX MONTHS AND INCLUDED
PARTICIPANTS FROM ADVOCACY
GROUPS, STATE AGENCIES,
FACILITIES, PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS AND MEDICAL GROUPS.
THE REPORT, WITH ITS FINDINGS
WERE PUBLISHED IN OCTOBER OF
LAST YEAR AND THE WORKGROUP WAS
CLEAR IN ITS TAKEAWAY, IT IS
THIS QUOTE FROM THE REPORT. IT
IS ESSENTIAL FOR FAMILY AND
FRIENDS TO HAVE ACCESS TO
RESIDENTS, INCLUDING DURING A
STATE OF EMERGENCY. AT ITS CORE,
AB 2075 RECOGNIZES THE
CONSEQUENTIAL ROLE THAT LOVED
ONES PLAY IN ENSURING THAT
RESIDENTS RECEIVE THE ATTENTION.
THE LOVE AND THE CARE THAT THEY
NEED, WHICH AUGMENTS THE ROLE OF
FACILITY STAFF. WE REMAIN
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
OPPOSITION TO FIND MORE MIDDLE
GROUND TO ENSURE THAT WE BALANCE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY WITH
VISITATION RIGHTS TO THAT END,
WE HAVE UNILATERALLY ADDED
COMPROMISE PROVISIONS THAT SEEK
TO MEET THEM IN THE MIDDLE. THE
PROVISIONS INCLUDE FLEXIBILITY
FOR STATE AND LOCAL AUTHORITIES
WHEN HANDLING PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCIES, BY AUTHORIZING THEM
TO DEFINE HOW VISITORS CAN
DEMONSTRATE PROFICIENCY IN
FOLLOWING SAFETY PROTOCOLS,
CAPPING THE AMOUNT OF VISITORS
WHO CAN VISIT SIMULTANEOUSLY,
AND EVEN THE ABILITY TO
INSTITUTE A SEVEN DAY LOCK OUT
PERIOD WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXTEND IT SEVEN MORE DAYS IF
THEY FEEL IS NECESSARY. I HAVE
ALSO CLARIFIED THAT STAFF WILL
BE PRIORITIZED AS IT RELATES TO
PPE USE, AND LOVED ONES CAN ONLY
VISIT IF THEY FOLLOW THE SAME
SAFETY PROTOCOLS AS STAFF, WHICH
INCLUDES THE DONNING OF PPE
THROUGH COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS IN
PREVIOUS COMMITTEES. AND THIS
ONE, I HAVE CLARIFIED THAT THE
GOVERNOR CAN SUPERSEDE THIS ACT
THROUGH HIS EMERGENCY POWERS AND
THAT PUBLIC HEALTH ORDER THAT
REQUIRES AN EVACUATION NOTICE
WOULD NOT BE SUBJECT TO THIS
BILL. THIS IS ONE OF THE BILLS
IN THIS SESSION THAT I HAVE
REALLY ATTEMPTED TO GO ABOVE AND
BEYOND TO FIND THAT MIDDLE
GROUND, AND I WILL CONTINUE TO
DO THAT AS I DO WITH ALL MY
LEGISLATION TO TRY TO OFFER
SOLUTIONS. WE CAN GET INTO THE
DETAILS OF WHAT WE'VE DONE TO
DATE TO AMEND THE BILL, TO BRING
IT TO WHAT IT IS TODAY. BUT AT
THE END OF THE DAY, THIS IS A
BILL THAT RECOGNIZES THAT
DURING, UNFORTUNATE
CIRCUMSTANCES LIKE PANDEMICS, IT
IS STILL IMPORTANT AND NECESSARY
FOR US TO HAVE ACCESS TO OUR
LOVED ONES WHO ARE IN FACILITIES
WHERE THEY ARE BEING CARED FOR.
AND, YOU WILL HEAR SOME
TESTIMONY FROM INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE HAD EXPERIENCE IN THIS. AND
SO I'LL ASK TONY CHICOTEL FIRST
FROM THE CALIFORNIA NURSING HOME
REFORM, TO BE OUR FIRST WITNESS.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY. THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK
ABOUT THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL.
AND THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR ITS GREAT ANALYSIS,
ONE OF THE ENDURING HORRORS OF
THE COVID PANDEMIC WAS THE
IMMENSE SUFFERING IN NURSING
HOMES. THERE WAS SO MUCH DEATH
AND DESPONDENCY. MANY DEATHS
WERE DUE TO COVID AND MANY
DEATHS WERE DUE TO THE NEGLECT,
FUELED BY UNDERSTAFFING AND THE
TERRIBLE MISTAKE OF LOCKING OUT
FAMILY AND FRIENDS WHO PROVIDED
LIFE SUSTAINING CARE. WE CUT OFF
MANY RESIDENTS LIFELINES
UNRELENTINGLY. MONTH AFTER
MONTH, WE HAD REPORTS OF
RESIDENTS WITH COGNITIVE
IMPAIRMENT WHO DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND, COULDN'T UNDERSTAND
WHY THEIR FAMILIES WEREN'T
SHOWING UP ANYMORE. WE HAD LGBTQ
RESIDENTS WHO TALKED ABOUT BEING
RETRAUMATIZED, WHO HAD SURVIVED
THE 1980S AIDS EPIDEMIC, FEELING
RETRAUMATIZED ONCE AGAIN WITH
ALL OF THE ISOLATION IMPOSED ON
THEM. LAST YEAR, AT THE BEHEST
OF THE LEGISLATURE, 35
ORGANIZATIONS AND GROUPS
PARTICIPATED IN THE STATEWIDE
WORKGROUP TO RECOMMEND BEST
PRACTICES FOR HOW TO, DEAL WITH
ACCESS DURING PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCIES. WE WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE BALANCE, ACCESS TO
THE PEOPLE WHO LOVE THESE
RESIDENTS THE MOST AND ENSURE
THAT THE ACCESS DID NOT UNDULY
ENDANGER THEM. THE WORKGROUP'S
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE THE ROADMAP
FOR AB 2075. RESIDENTS ARE
GUARANTEED ACCESS TO THE PEOPLE
WHO CARE FOR THEM BEST, WHILE
GIVING STATE AND LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS THE ABILITY TO
IMPOSE ANY SAFETY MEASURES THEY
FEEL ARE NECESSARY TO ENSURE
RESIDENTS SAFETY, SO LONG AS
THEY ARE NO MORE STRINGENT THAN
THOSE THAT ARE IMPOSED ON THE
STAFF. YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
THE BILL OPPONENTS THAT AB 2075
RESTRICTS THEIR ABILITY TO
RESPOND TO EMERGENCIES, THAT THE
BILL LIMITS THEIR OPTIONS. AB
2075 IS NOT ABOUT RESTRICTIONS
ON TOOLS OR TACTICS. PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICERS RETAIN THEIR
ABILITY TO SET SAFETY PROTOCOLS
OR TO EVEN ISOLATE LONG TERM
CARE RESIDENTS. WHAT AB 2075
DOES IS CODIFY A FOUNDATIONAL
PRINCIPLE THAT FAMILY SUPPORT IS
EVERY BIT AS IMPORTANT AS STAFF
SUPPORT FOR THE HEALTH AND
WELL-BEING OF LONG TERM CARE
RESIDENTS. THE BILL ENSURES THAT
NOBODY CAN TELL A FAMILY SUPPORT
PERSON THAT THEY ARE LESS
ESSENTIAL TO THE WELFARE OF A
RESIDENT THAN A STAFF PERSON.
PLEASE VOTE YES ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL. THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT. PLEASE MA'AM, PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF FOR THE
RECORD. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME
IS MADELINE WISEMAN. I'M A
FAMILY CAREGIVER AND CO-FOUNDER
OF THE ESSENTIAL CAREGIVERS
COALITION. I'VE PROVIDED CARE
FOR MY MOM, CELIA, FOR AS LONG
AS I CAN REMEMBER. SINCE SHE WAS
YOUNG, SHE'S NAVIGATED A
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY,
INCOMPLETE QUADRIPLEGIA, AND A
COMMUNICATION DISORDER. MY
CAREGIVING CONTINUED WHEN SHE
MOVED INTO A MEMORY CARE HOME
AND RCF. I AUGMENT STAFF CARE
DAILY. I BRING A STRAW OR A
SPOON TO HER LIPS. OTHERWISE SHE
CANNOT EAT OR DRINK. I ALSO HELP
HER TO BATHE, DRESS, TOILET
TRANSFER, MOVE ABOUT AND
COMMUNICATE. I KNOW HER
NONVERBAL CUES AND I HELP OTHERS
LEARN THEM. PANDEMIC VISITOR
RESTRICTIONS ABRUPTLY STOPPED
ALL OF THAT SUPPORT. THEY FAILED
TO RECOGNIZE FAMILY CAREGIVING
AS URGENT AND ESSENTIAL WORK. MY
MOM RAPIDLY LOST WEIGHT AND
BECAME AGITATED, WITHDRAWN,
DEPRESSED, AND SOMETIMES
UNRESPONSIVE. HER ALREADY
LIMITED COMMUNICATION SKILLS
DWINDLED FURTHER, WITH HIGH
STAFF TURNOVER. NO ONE NOTED
THESE CHANGES, NOR THE BRUISES,
RASHES, BAD HYGIENE, LETHARGY,
DEHYDRATION AND DELIRIUM.
INCREASED E.R. VISITS REVEALED
UNUSUAL BLOOD PRESSURE,
DANGEROUS LEVELS OF DEHYDRATION,
CONTUSION, A BROKEN CLAVICLE,
ASPIRATION PNEUMONIA, AND
RECURRENT C DIFF, ALL IN THE
FIRST SEVERAL MONTHS OF
LOCKDOWNS THAT WERE SUPPOSED TO
PROTECT HER IN A VULNERABLE
PERSON UNCHECKED DEHYDRATION CAN
BE DEADLY IN A MATTER OF DAYS.
NOW, WE KNOW THAT IN A PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY, STAFF DWINDLES
AND TURNS OVER CONSTANTLY. PLUS,
EMERGENCY WAIVERS PERMIT NEW
HIRES TO HAVE NO TRAINING, NO
EXPERIENCE, AND NO BACKGROUND
CHECKS WITH OUT CONSISTENCY IN
CAREGIVING. MY MOM WASN'T
GETTING HELP TO DRINK AND EAT
NEW HIRES AND AGENCY STAFF
DIDN'T STAY LONG ENOUGH TO LEARN
TO BRING THE STRAW TO HER LIPS
OR TO RECOGNIZE HER THIRST CUES.
I WATCHED MY MOM STRUGGLE TO
SURVIVE BECAUSE FAMILY
CAREGIVERS WERE LOCKED OUT,
MISSED, CATEGORIZED, AND
UNDERUTILIZED. BUT THEN
SOMETHING WENT RIGHT FOR US.
ANYWAY, FIRST, IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT HOSPITALS ALWAYS LET
ME IN TO STAY BY HER SIDE 24
OVER SEVEN IN PROPER PPE FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING. THAT'S
THANKS TO THE ADA. WE DON'T HAVE
THAT IN LONG TERM CARE, THOUGH.
BUT AGAINST ALL THE RULES IN
THAT PRE-VACCINE TIME, HER
FACILITIES MANAGEMENT CHOSE TO
LET ME INSIDE TO AT FIRST ON A
LIMITED BASIS, AND THEN 24 OVER
SEVEN WHEN THEY SAW HOW MUCH I
FREED UP STAFF TO FOCUS ON OTHER
RESIDENTS AND REDUCE THEIR PPE
BURDEN BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T HAVE
TO COME INTO HER ROOM SO OFTEN,
WHICH MEANS DONNING AND DOFFING
EACH TIME DURING THEIR BIGGEST
COVID OUTBREAK. MY MOM WAS STILL
RECOVERING FROM C DIFF AND
STAFFING WAS THINNER THAN EVER,
SO I MOVED IN TO FOLLOW ALL
PRECAUTIONS FOR BOTH COVID AND C
DIFF. I SLEPT IN AN N95 MASK,
EYE PROTECTION, A GOWN, GLOVES
AND BOOTIES, AND THANKFULLY WE
BOTH REMAINED COVID NEGATIVE
BECAUSE THE FACILITY TOOK A RARE
LEAP OF FAITH AND GRANTED ME
EARLY ACCESS. I WAS ABLE TO GET
HER ALMOST ALL THE WAY BACK TO
HER BASELINE HEALTH, AND SHE IS
THRIVING TODAY. OUR STORY IS A
MODEL FOR WHAT COULD BE IF
FAMILY CAREGIVERS ARE RECOGNIZED
AS ESSENTIAL RESOURCES IN PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCIES, WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE NEXT INFECTIOUS
DISEASE WILL BRING, BUT
LOGICALLY, IF ANY TIME A STAFF
CAREGIVER IS ALLOWED TO ENTER
WITH PRECAUTIONS, SO CAN A
RESIDENT'S DESIGNATED SUPPORT
PERSON. IT'S ALL HANDS ON DECK
DURING THESE TIMES. I ALSO URGE
AGAINST ARBITRARY WAITING
PERIODS WHEN IT MAKES SENSE TO
TIE FAMILY CAREGIVER ACCESS TO
STAFF, CAREGIVER ACCESS AND
PROTOCOLS. IN SOME CASES, LIKE
SEVERE HYDRATION, FOR EXAMPLE,
FOR SOMEONE LIKE MY MOM, A MERE
FEW DAYS COULD BE TOO LONG TO
WAIT. PLEASE SUPPORT AB 2075,
HELP US BECOME COLLABORATORS AND
GOOD PUBLIC HEALTH OUTCOMES.
MAKE FAMILY CAREGIVERS RESIDENT
DESIGNATED SUPPORT PERSONS.
ANOTHER TOOL IN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH ARSENAL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU FOR COMING TO
SPEAK TO US TODAY. ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE, NAME, POSITION,
AFFILIATION RATHER, AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE ONLY IF I COULD
ASK DANITA STROMGREN VOLUNTEER
WITH AARP CALIFORNIA,
REPRESENTING OUR 3.2 MILLION
MEMBERS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MA'AM.
NEXT, PLEASE. ABBY ALVAREZ WITH
LEADING AGE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. YES, MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIRMAN BLANCA
CASTRO, STATE LONG-TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN, OAN, CO-SPONSOR AND
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
HELLO. JASON SULLIVAN HALPERN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LONGTERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU, SIR.
NOW LET'S TURN TO OPPOSITION. IF
ANY OPPOSITION WITNESSES FIRST
WILL TAKE THE LEAD. OPPOSITION
WITNESS. YOU'RE WELCOME TO JOIN
US AT THE WITNESSES. YOU'RE
WELCOME TO JOIN US AT THE TABLE
HERE. AND WE'LL GET TO THE REST
IN A MOMENT. PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELVES FOR THE RECORD AND
PROCEED WHEN READY.
GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIR. MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. I'M DOCTOR KEN
CUTLER WITH THE HEALTH OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. WE
APPRECIATE THE INTENT OF AB 2075
TO SUPPORT RESIDENTS IN LONG
TERM CARE FACILITIES AND HOPE
VISITATION IS NEVER CURTAILED
AGAIN. BUT WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB 2075 BECAUSE IT PLACES
SIGNIFICANT LIMITATIONS ON
EMERGENCY RESPONSE THAT COULD
HINDER FUTURE EFFORTS TO PROTECT
HEALTH AND SAFETY. WHEN
CONSIDERING THIS BILL, I ASK
THAT YOU CONSIDER NOT WHAT COVID
LANDSCAPE LOOKS LIKE NOW. WHEN
WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT POPULATION
IMMUNITY, PLENTY OF VACCINE, AND
IMPROVED MEDICAL TREATMENT. BUT
REMEMBER WHAT IT LOOKED LIKE IN
EARLY 2020? WE HAD A NOVEL VIRUS
WE DIDN'T FULLY UNDERSTAND, AND
NO VACCINE AVAILABLE AND HARDLY
ANY TESTING CAPACITY. WHERE I
WORKED, WE HAD SIX COUNTIES
USING ONE PUBLIC HEALTH LAB THAT
COULD RUN 20 TO 40 TESTS A DAY,
COMPARED TO MORE THAN 300,000
TESTS A DAY IN CALIFORNIA BY THE
END OF THAT YEAR. WE ALSO HAD
INADEQUATE SUPPLIES OF PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT, HEALTH
CARE WORKERS AND FACILITY STAFF
PUT THEIR LIVES AT RISK COMING
TO WORK. AND PLEASE DON'T FORGET
THAT 40% OF ALL COVID DEATHS IN
CALIFORNIA, IN THOSE EARLY
MONTHS HAPPENED IN LONG TERM
CARE FACILITY RESIDENTS AND
STAFF, AND FUTURE SCENARIOS
COULD BE WORSE WHEN FACED WITH
CHALLENGING AND COMPLEX
EMERGENCIES. HEALTH OFFICERS
BALANCE THE MEASURES USED WITH
THE MAGNITUDE AND NATURE OF THE
THREAT. THE COVID PANDEMIC WAS
UNPRECEDENTED AND OUTBREAKS
THEMSELVES IN LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES HAD DEVASTATING
CONSEQUENCES. SO ANY ACTION TO
LIMIT VISITATION WERE NEVER
TAKEN LIGHTLY. NEVER INTENDED TO
BE PUNITIVE. THEY WERE ISSUED
OUT OF CARE AND CONCERN, AND
OFTEN PUT THE HEALTH OFFICIAL AT
PERSONAL AND PROFESSIONAL RISK.
AND THERE ARE GUARDRAILS. HEALTH
OFFICER ORDERS NEED TO BE
REASONABLE, NARROWLY TAILORED TO
THE OBJECTIVE AND CAN BE
CHALLENGED AND ORDERS EVOLVED AS
KNOWLEDGE INCREASED. VACCINES
AND IMMUNITY EMERGED AND THE
VIRUS CHANGED. WE ABSOLUTELY
RECOGNIZE THAT SOCIAL
CONNECTIONS ARE VITAL AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT VISITATION
UNTIL IT ENDANGERS HEALTH AND
SAFETY, AND THAT SHOULD HAPPEN
ONLY RARELY PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC, PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS
HAD NOT IMPOSED LONG TERM
RESTRICTIONS ON VISITATION. AND
AGAIN, WE HOPE NEVER TO DO SO
AGAIN. BUT UNFORTUNATELY, WE
KNOW COMMUNICABLE DISEASES CAN
AND DO EVOLVE QUICKLY AND SPREAD
RAPIDLY, AND NONE OF US KNOWS
HOW SEVERE THE NEXT ONE WILL BE.
WHO WILL BE MOST VULNERABLE, AND
WHAT SPECIFIC PROTECTIVE
MEASURES WILL BE NEEDED. AB 2075
DICTATES THAT EVEN IN A DECLARED
EMERGENCY, LOCAL ORDERS CANNOT
SUSPEND, SUPERSEDE OR MODIFY THE
MEASURE EXCEPT IN NARROW WAYS
AND WITHOUT REGARD TO THE NATURE
OR TYPE OF EMERGENCY. WE
THEREFORE RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
YOU OPPOSE AB 2075. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE, MR.
CHAIR, AND MEMBERS, BETSY
ARMSTRONG WITH THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION AND
REGRETFULLY, ALSO IN AN OPPOSED
POSITION. THE COVID 19 PANDEMIC
WAS UNPRECEDENTED AND
UNPRECEDENTED ACTIONS WERE TAKEN
WITH THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
CALIFORNIANS FRONT OF MIND.
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS WORKED
TIRELESSLY TO UNDERSTAND THE
VIRUS AND PROTECT COMMUNITIES
UNDER CONSTANTLY CHANGING
CONDITIONS. PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS HAVE BEEN SCRUTINIZED,
HARASSED AND EVEN THREATENED FOR
IMPLEMENTING PUBLIC HEALTH
MEASURES THAT WE KNOW SAVE LIVES
. WE ABSOLUTELY ACKNOWLEDGE THE
VALUE AND IMPORTANCE OF FAMILY
AND VISITORS TO RESIDENTS IN
THESE FACILITIES. SINCE THE
START OF THE PANDEMIC, LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS HAVE GAINED
PRAGMATIC AND ACTIONABLE
EXPERIENCE AND HAVE ALREADY
BEGUN IMPLEMENTING LESSONS
LEARNED. HEALTH DEPARTMENTS HAVE
SINCE IMPROVED LINES OF
COMMUNICATION AND HAVE HIRED
INFECTION PREVENTIONISTS TO WORK
WITH THESE FACILITIES TO KEEP
RESIDENTS HEALTHY AND MINIMIZE
THE SPREAD OF DISEASE. HOWEVER,
WE MUST BE MINDFUL OF POTENTIAL
PUBLIC HEALTH THREATS THAT COULD
ENDANGER RESIDENTS, FACILITY
STAFF AND OUR COMMUNITIES. THOSE
THREATS COULD BE KNOWN, LIKE
EBOLA OR ANOTHER UNKNOWN NOVEL
VIRUS THAT PUBLIC HEALTH WILL
HAVE TO LEARN AND RESPOND TO
OUTBREAKS START LOCALLY.
DISEASES KNOW NO BOUNDARIES, AND
PEOPLE TRAVEL ACROSS COUNTY
LINES EVERY DAY, WHETHER FOR
WORK, RECREATION OR TO VISIT
LOVED ONES. THE FASTER WE STOP
THE SPREAD OF A DISEASE LOCALLY,
THE BETTER. PROTECTED ALL
CALIFORNIANS WILL BE. AND WHILE
WE CANNOT PREDICT WHEN THERE MAY
BE ANOTHER TIME, HOPEFULLY NEVER
WHERE STOPPING THE SPREAD MEANS
PAUSING VISITATION IN THESE
FACILITIES BECAUSE THE PUBLIC
HEALTH THREAT IS SO SIGNIFICANT.
SINCE THE TIME THIS BILL WAS
INTRODUCED, CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS HAVE
RESPONDED TO VARIOUS MEASLES
CASES, A TB OUTBREAK, SHIGELLA
OUTBREAKS, HEP A, AND
LEGIONNAIRES DISEASE. AMONG
OTHERS, BUT WITHOUT ANY CHANGES
TO VISITATION. DEMONSTRATE THAT
IT'S NEVER OUR FIRST RESPONSE TO
INFECTIOUS DISEASE. WE
APPRECIATE THE ENGAGEMENT WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND THE
PROPONENTS OF THIS BILL.
HOWEVER, WE'VE BEEN UNABLE TO
REACH A BALANCE BETWEEN ALIGNING
VISITATION IN A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDANCE AND MEASURES. AND WHILE
THE AUTHOR'S PROPOSED AMENDMENT,
AS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS, WOULD
ALLOW PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS TO
SUSPEND VISITATION FOR A MAXIMUM
OF 14 DAYS, 14 DAYS MAY NOT BE
ENOUGH TIME TO ENSURE THE
APPROPRIATE MEASURES ARE IN
PLACE TO PROTECT RESIDENTS,
WORKERS AND OUR COMMUNITIES.
PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE IS
TAILORED TO THE THREAT IT
CONSIDERS WHO IS THE MOST
VULNERABLE, THE PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT, HOSPITAL
BEDS, RESOURCE AVAILABILITY
INCLUDING WHETHER THERE'S A
VACCINE TO PREVENT THE SPREAD OR
MEDICATION TO MINIMIZE THE
EFFECTS OF THE DISEASE. AND IT
EVOLVES AS THE SCIENCE EVOLVES.
AB 2075 WOULD LEAVE PUBLIC
HEALTH WITH LESS TOOLS TO
PROTECT LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES AND OUR COMMUNITIES
AT LARGE. WHEN THE NEXT PUBLIC
HEALTH THREAT COMES AND IT'S NOT
A MATTER OF IF, IT'S A MATTER OF
WHEN, IT'S FOR THOSE REASONS. WE
MUST OPPOSE AB 2075. THANK YOU.
OKAY. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION WITNESSES? NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE ONLY. PLEASE MR. CHAIR
MEMBERS VICTORIA RODRIGUEZ WITH
NIELSEN MERKSAMER. ON BEHALF OF
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON. JARED MOSS, ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF LONG BEACH AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, DILLON
ELLIOTT, ON BEHALF OF NAPA
COUNTY IN OPPOSITION, AS WELL AS
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO, CURRENTLY IN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
AS OUTLINED IN THEIR LETTER TO
THE COMMITTEE AND AUTHOR. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION WITNESSES? SEEING
NONE, I'M GOING TO BRING IT BACK
TO THE DAIS BEFORE I TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES. LET ME
JUST ASK A COUPLE QUESTIONS OF
THOSE OPPOSED, YOU KNOW, GIVEN
THE FACT THAT THE BILL PERMITS A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ORDER TO
SUPERSEDE THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL DURING A DECLARED STATE OF
EMERGENCY, TO LIMIT VISITATION,
AT LEAST IN TERMS OF
SIMULTANEOUS VISITATION, OR TO
REQUIRE VISITORS TO FOLLOW
CERTAIN SAFETY PROTOCOLS OR ALSO
REQUIRED OF FACULTY AND STAFF,
AND THE REQUIREMENT THAT
VISITORS, YOU KNOW, DON
APPROPRIATE PPE AND GO THROUGH
TRAINING AND THEN ALSO, OF
COURSE, THE AMENDMENT THAT
RESERVES TO THE GOVERNOR THE
POWER TO DECLARE A STATE OF
EMERGENCY UNDER THE EMERGENCY
SERVICES ACT, WHICH MY
UNDERSTANDING IS, DOES NOT
CONTAIN ANY SORT OF DAY OR MONTH
LIMITATION. THÀNH, DON'T YOU
BELIEVE THAT THAT'S ENOUGH TO
PROVIDE LOCALS WITH SUFFICIENT
AUTHORITY AND PROTECTION UNDER
THIS BILL? IF IT'S THAT SERIOUS
AN EVENT, EVEN IF IT'S IN ONE
COUNTY? DO YOU NOT THINK THAT
THE GOVERNOR IS GOING TO
EXERCISE THEIR AUTHORITY TO, TO,
DECLARE A STATE OF EMERGENCY,
WHETHER IT'S IN THAT COUNTY OR A
REGION OR THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA? YOU WOULD HOPE IN
THE. I WOULD HOPE IN THE RIGHT
CIRCUMSTANCE THAT THE RIGHT
GOVERNOR WOULD DO THE RIGHT
THING FOR THE COUNTY. IT GOES WE
HAVE HAD A LONG STANDING
PRINCIPLE OF LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
AUTHORITY AUTHORITIES. THEY KNOW
THEIR COMMUNITIES BEST. THEY
KNOW THEIR FACILITIES BEST.
NGUYEN, IN TERMS OF THE LOCAL
SEVEN DAYS WITH SEVEN DAYS
EXTENSION, AGAIN, WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE SPECIFIC NEXT THREAT
WILL LOOK LIKE. THERE ARE MANY,
INFECTIOUS DISEASES WITH VERY
LONG INCUBATION PERIODS. THAT
COULD TAKE LONGER, THAN SEVEN
DAYS. AND ALSO THE BILL WAS
EXPANDED. SO IT'S NOT JUST
DESIGNATED SUPPORT PERSONS WHO
KNOW THE RESIDENTS WELL. IT'S
ALL VISITORS WHO CAN COME IN AND
IN TERMS OF THE CAP ON
SIMULTANEOUS, THAT'S A CAP OF A
SIMULTANEOUS VISIT PER RESIDENT.
THERE ARE FACILITIES WITH OVER
100 RESIDENTS. THAT IS A LOT OF
VISITORS. AND EVERY TIME. BUT
THE BILL JUST NOT TO INTERRUPT
YOU, BUT THE BILL PERMITS A
STATE OR LOCAL GOVERNMENT ORDER
TO STATE THE TERMS BY WHICH
VISITORS OR HEALTH CARE AND
SOCIAL SERVICE PROVIDERS SO
VISITORS AND PROVIDERS CAN
DEMONSTRATE THEIR PROFICIENCY TO
FOLLOW THE SAME SAFETY PROTOCOLS
OF STAFF. AND I THOUGHT THERE
WAS ANOTHER PROVISION HERE THAT,
STATE PERMITS STATE OR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ORDER TO SUPERSEDE
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL
DURING A STATE OF EMERGENCY, TO
LIMIT THE NUMBER OF VISITORS OR
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS WHO MAY
SIMULTANEOUSLY VISIT A
RESIDENCE. SO THERE IS SOME
AUTHORITY NOTWITHSTANDING THE OR
THE AMENDMENT TO ALLOW LOCALS TO
CONTROL THAT. AGAIN, I WOULD SAY
THAT'S IN A VERY NARROW WAY.
IT'S NOT LIMITING. THERE'S NO
FULL CAP ON LIMITATION. IT'S
LIMITING THE NUMBER OF
SIMULTANEOUS VISITS FOR A
RESIDENT. BUT DON'T. BUT
WOULDN'T YOU, FOR EXAMPLE, IF
THE BILL, IF WE HAD AN EBOLA
SITUATION OR SOMETHING EVEN
WORSE? BY THE WAY, EBOLA. I WENT
TO EMORY UNIVERSITY. EBOLA WAS
DOWN AT EMORY. I WATCHED THE
WHOLE, OPERATION DOWN THERE,
WORK OR NOT. BUT IF WE HAD A
SITUATION LIKE THAT IN ONE OF
OUR 58 COUNTIES, OR MAYBE TWO,
WOULD NOT THE LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICIALS, IF THEY FELT THIS
BILL INTERFERED WITH THEIR
AUTHORITY TO PROPERLY MANAGE THE
SITUATION, REACH OUT TO THE
STATE HEALTH OFFICER AND THE
GOVERNOR AND REQUEST A
DECLARATION OF EMERGENCY. THEY
WOULD. DON'T YOU THINK THAT THE
GOVERNOR WOULD RESPOND IN THAT
SITUATION IF IN FACT, YOU HAD
COMPELLING REASONS TO DO MORE
THAN THIS BILL ALLOWS YOU TO DO
THAT. HAVING THE GOVERNOR HAVE
THE ABILITY TO SUPERSEDE IS AN
IMPROVEMENT IN THE BILL. WE
THINK THAT THE LOCAL SHOULD ALSO
HAVE THE AUTHORITY, KNOWING
THERE JURISDICTION BEST AND IN
PRINCIPLE WITH THE TRADITIONS OF
PUBLIC HEALTH THAT HAVE STOOD
CALIFORNIA IN GOOD STEAD, AND IN
TERMS OF EBOLA, IN TERMS OF THE
PUTTING, DONNING AND DOFFING OF
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT,
WE CAN SAY THE CONDITIONS IN
WHICH PEOPLE COULD DEMONSTRATE
THEIR USE OF IT. IT TAKES A TEAM
TO DO THAT AND, JUST
DEMONSTRATING THE ABILITY. IT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT YOU CAN
MAINTAIN IT THROUGH A LONG
VISITATION. WE DON'T KNOW WHO'S
GOING TO BE MONITORING THAT
SITUATION, WHO'S GOING TO BE
REPORTING BREAKS IN IN PROTECT
EQUIPMENT, EQUIPMENT, THAT TYPE
OF THING. SO THERE AND ALSO IF
YOU THINK ABOUT ALL OF THE
EFFORTS TO DO THAT, THAT WILL BE
TAKING STAFF TIME AWAY, TO TRAIN
DOING THAT. WELL PEOPLE NEED
CARE IN THESE IN THESE
SITUATIONS. WELL, I'M NOT I'M
NOT I DON'T NECESSARILY DON'T
RECALL, BUT I'M NOT SURE THAT
THE BILL REQUIRES THAT YOU TAKE
STAFF AWAY TO DO THE TRAINING.
SOMETHING YOU NEED TO TRAINING
NEEDS TO BE PROVIDED BY SOMEONE.
THAT'S CORRECT. YOU KNOW, THE
OTHER THING IS IN WE HAVE 58
COUNTIES AND WE HAVE 50 LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS. AND I AM FAIRLY
CERTAIN, LIKE ANY OTHER
OCCUPATION IN LIFE, THERE ARE
DIFFERING LEVELS OF ABILITY AND
DIFFERING LEVELS OF EXPERIENCE.
SO I'M NOT SURE THAT IT'S
INAPPROPRIATE TO RELY ON THE
GOVERNOR AND THE HEALTH
OPERATION UP HERE IN SACRAMENTO
IN IN THE MOST SERIOUS AND
CRITICAL OF CASES TO CALL THE
SHOT, AS OPPOSED TO LETTING THE
SHOT BE CALLED 58 DIFFERENT WAYS
AND 58 DIFFERENT COUNTIES. BUT I
GUESS THAT'S JUST ME. LET ME
TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES IN
CASE ANYONE HAS ANY QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. SENATOR
GONZALEZ. YES, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND THANK YOU FOR THE
FIRST QUESTION, BECAUSE I DID
OBVIOUSLY HAVE THAT SAME
QUESTION IN TERMS OF THE
RETENTION OF LOCAL AUTHORITY.
COME FROM LONG BEACH. I'VE GOT
MY OWN HEALTH DEPARTMENT. LIKE I
OFTEN, MENTION TO FOLKS, IT'S
NOT JUST LOS ANGELES COUNTY,
IT'S THE CITY OF LONG BEACH'S
HEALTH DEPARTMENT. AND I KNOW
YOU'VE RECEIVED THE OPPOSITION
LETTER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. YOU MAY
HAVE, BUT RELATIVE TO THAT
LETTER, IT DOES IT. YOU KNOW, I
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE DOING
HERE, AND I COMPLETELY, FEEL AS
THOUGH FOLKS DO NEED THAT EXTRA
CARE AND THAT EXTRA VISITOR. I
ABSOLUTELY BELIEVE THAT, I HAVE
HAD FRIENDS WHO'VE HAD FAMILY
MEMBERS THAT HAVE PASSED DURING
COVID WITH NO ONE THERE, AND
THAT'S VERY HEARTBREAKING.
ABSOLUTELY, BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT
IN IN LONG BEACH SPECIFICALLY,
WE DID A PRETTY DARN GOOD JOB. I
WILL SAY OUR DOCTOR, ANISSA
DAVIS, WHO I HOPE YOU WOULD
CONNECT WITH AFTER THIS, MOVES
ON IF IT SHOULD MOVE ON, ONE OF
THE BEST, I WOULD SAY HEALTH
DIRECTORS IN ALL OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, AND SHE IS STILL
VERY STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS.
SO IT WILL BE HARD FOR ME TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY TOO. BUT
AS BEEN MENTIONED, THE RETENTION
OF LOCAL AUTHORITY IS SETTING A
PRECEDENT, THE RESOURCE
LIMITATIONS, AS MENTIONED, YOU
KNOW, THE PPE, WHICH YOU SAID
YOU WOULD ADDRESS. SO I'LL ASK
YOU ABOUT THAT, I THINK FIRST,
AND THEN I'LL GO ON TO OTHERS.
YEAH, I DON'T HAVE THE CITY OF
LONG BEACH LETTER IN FRONT OF
ME, SO I CAN'T I CAN'T REFERENCE
IT. UNFORTUNATELY WHAT I WOULD
SAY IS, AND YOU HEARD IT IN THE
EXCHANGE BETWEEN THE CHAIR AND
THE TESTIMONY OF THE WITNESSES,
WE HAVE TRIED TO GET TO A POINT
AGAIN WITH THIS BILL. AS I SAID
IN MY OPENING STATEMENT, MORE
THAN ANY BILL THIS SESSION OF
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
ACHIEVE THE GOAL THAT YOU JUST
MENTIONED, THE GOAL OF ENSURING
THAT INDIVIDUALS HAVE ACCESS TO
THEIR LOVED ONES DURING THESE
THESE TYPES OF CRISES. I ALSO
DIDN'T I DIDN'T MENTION THIS IN
MY OPENING, BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO MENTION THIS IS
THAT THIS BILL ISN'T JUST AN
IDEA THAT JUST CAME OUT OF
NOWHERE, AND IT WAS A FEW YEARS
AGO THAT, A COLLEAGUE IN THE
ASSEMBLY INTRODUCED AND WAS
ATTEMPTING TO INTRODUCE THE THIS
BILL, ACTUALLY, AND AS A RESULT
OF THE PROCESS, THE BILL BECAME
A STUDY OR A WORKING GROUP, AND
IT REQUIRED THAT PEOPLE MEET AND
COME UP WITH SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS, SO THIS BILL IS
ACTUALLY BASED ON
RECOMMENDATIONS OF MONTHS OF
WORK, OF INPUT FROM THE
STAKEHOLDERS, ALL THAT YOU SEE
AT THE TABLE, AND IN FACT, THE
BILL, SOME MIGHT ARGUE, IS MORE
LIMITING THAN THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT CAME OUT OF
OUT OF THAT REPORT. AND SO WE
HAVE ATTEMPTED IN THE LATEST
VERSION, WHICH IS MY SUGGESTION,
IT WAS NOT FROM OPPOSITION, IS
LET'S GIVE AT LEAST A SEVEN DAY
BREAK PERIOD SO THAT PEOPLE CAN
KIND OF, FIND THEIR FEET IN
DURING A TIME OF, OF, OF THIS
TYPE OF PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY.
YOU JUST DON'T KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING. SO I HEARD THAT
ARGUMENT. I SAID, OKAY, WELL,
LET'S GIVE THEM SOME TIME. LET'S
GIVE THEM SEVEN DAYS AND GIVE
THEM AN ADDITIONAL SEVEN DAYS SO
THAT THEY CAN AGAIN FIND THEIR
FEET. AND HOPEFULLY BY THEN THEY
CAN ESTABLISH ALL OF THE
PROVISIONS THAT THEY REQUIRE FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO COME IN AND
VISIT, INCLUDING WHATEVER.
PROTECTION, PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
NEEDS TO BE WORN OR ANY OTHER
GUIDANCE THAT NEEDS TO BE
FOLLOWED. AND SO WE'VE ATTEMPTED
TO GET TO A PLACE WHERE THIS
MIGHT NOT BE RESOLVED. IF THE
OPPOSITION MAY JUST FEEL AND THE
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIAL IN LONG
BEACH MAY JUST FEEL, THAT THEY
SHOULD ALWAYS JUST MAKE THE
DECISION OF WHEN TO ALLOW
VISITORS. AND IF THAT'S THE
POSITION, WHICH QUITE HONESTLY,
I THINK THAT'S REALLY THE
POSITION OF PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS, I DON'T KNOW THAT
THERE'S GOING TO BE A COMMON
GROUND. I COME FROM THE POSITION
OF RESPECTING PUBLIC HEALTH, AND
WE HAVE TO WE HAVE TO DO THAT.
AND I THINK THERE'S MEASURES
WITHIN THE BILL TO DO THAT, BUT
ALSO I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE HAVE ACCESS TO
VISITATION. AND SO AGAIN, THIS
MIGHT JUST BE ONE OF THOSE WHERE
THERE IS NO, NO WAY TO REALLY
COME TO AN AGREEMENT WITH, WITH
INDIVIDUALS WHO MIGHT JUST
DISAGREE WITH, WITH ALLOWING
FOLKS TO, TO VISIT THEIR LOVED
ONES DURING THESE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCIES. YEAH AND I WOULD
AND I, YOU KNOW, CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU HAVE TAKEN
AMENDMENTS TO MAKE THIS A LITTLE
BIT MORE FEASIBLE FOR
IMPLEMENTATION. I TOTALLY, THANK
YOU FOR THAT. BUT I DON'T THINK
THAT, HEALTH OFFICERS OR
CERTAINLY MY SPECIFIC HEALTH
OFFICER IN LONG BEACH DOES NOT
WANT TO ALLOW VISITORS. I THINK
THAT HAS BEEN MENTIONED BY ONE
OF THE OPPOSITION WITNESSES. IS
THAT THAT WOULD BE THE LAST
RESORT. RIGHT? WE TRY TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO ALLOW THE
VISITORS ALLOW MORE FLEXIBILITY.
FIRST BEFORE ENACTING A LOT OF
THESE REGULATIONS, WHICH QUITE
HONESTLY, WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE
TO DO. BUT WE'VE SEEN IT REALLY,
REALLY BAD. I MEAN, LONG BEACH,
I THINK HAD ONE OF THE BEST,
OUTCOMES BECAUSE WE WERE SO
PROACTIVE. AND YES, WE HAD TO
MAKE SOME REALLY TOUGH DECISIONS
. BUT I TRUSTED THAT OUR HEALTH
DIRECTOR MADE THOSE DECISIONS
WEIGHING ALL OF THIS, YOU KNOW,
EVERY CERTAIN FACTOR. BUT I
THINK IT DOES SET A PRECEDENT,
WHICH I'M A LITTLE WORRIED ABOUT
, THE VULNERABILITY OF OTHER
LONG TERM FACILITY CARE
RESIDENTS. ALSO, IS SOMETHING TO
CONSIDER. I KNOW YOU ARE
CONSIDERING THAT, BUT I JUST
THINK IF IT'S NOT JUST THAT ONE
PERSON THAT WANTS A VISITOR,
WHAT ABOUT THE REST OF THE
FACILITY RESIDENTS THAT MAY BE,
YOU KNOW, GETTING SOMETHING FROM
THAT OTHER VISITOR. AND IN LONG
BEACH, 500,000 RESIDENTS, 32
FACILITIES. THAT'S A LOT TO
MANAGE. SO IT'S HARD TO TELL A
HEALTH OFFICER THAT, YOU KNOW,
YOU'VE GOT MAYBE SEVEN DAYS TO
THINK ABOUT IT, I THINK IT'S A
LITTLE ARBITRARY. SO I'D LIKE TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH YOU ON
THIS. I WON'T SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY. I WOULD ASK THAT YOU DO
SPEAK TO OUR. AND I WOULD LOVE
TO CONVENE A MEETING WITH OUR
HEALTH DIRECTOR SO YOU CAN GET A
BIT OF AN UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
THE CITY'S HEALTH DEPARTMENT,
HOW THEY FUNCTION. AND YOU KNOW,
HOW WELL IT RAN. DESPITE ALL OF
THIS. SO WITH THAT, SURE. I JUST
IN RESPONSE, IF I MAY, I WOULD
JUST JUST SAY THAT WE DO THINK
THAT IF THIS REACHES A LEVEL AND
YOU HEARD SOME OF THE EXCHANGE
WITH THE CHAIR OF WHERE IT'S AN
EMERGENCY, THAT WE HAVE
RESPONSIBLE INDIVIDUALS IN THE
STATE AND THE PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS WOULD HAVE TIME,
WHETHER IT'S THE FIRST SEVEN DAY
PERIOD OR THE ADDITIONAL SEVEN
DAY PERIOD, TO REQUEST THAT THE
STATE DECLARE AN EMERGENCY TO
PREVENT THIS FROM HAPPENING. I
THINK, THAT AND YOU SAID IT'S
ARBITRARY. YES, IT IS ARBITRARY
BECAUSE THERE HAS BEEN NO
SUGGESTION OR OFFER ON HOW TO DO
THAT BETTER. I'M TRYING TO FIND
A WAY TO DO THIS BETTER. AND
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
THOUGHT WAS A REASONABLE WAY TO
APPROACH THIS. BUT I'M HAPPY TO,
YOU KNOW, CONTINUE TO TALK AS
LONG AS THERE'S, INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE WILLING TO GET TO THE
ENDPOINT OF ALLOWING VISITATION,
WHICH IS WHAT IS STATED AS A
DESIRE, AND WE'RE SAYING THE
SAME THING. TELL US WHAT OTHER
REQUIREMENTS YOU NEED TO ALLOW
VISITATION. WE'RE NOT HEARING
THAT. WE'RE HEARING. WE DON'T
WANT TO BE. WE DON'T WANT TO BE
TOLD THAT VISITATION SHOULD BE
ALLOWED. WE WANT TO MAKE THAT
DECISION ON OUR OWN WHENEVER WE
THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE. AND I
THINK THAT'S WHERE THE
FUNDAMENTAL DISAGREEMENT IS AND
WHERE PERHAPS WE MIGHT NOT BE
ABLE TO, FIND COMMON GROUND WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS
POTENTIALLY, BUT WILLING TO
CONTINUE TO TALK AS WE HAVE
BEEN. YEAH. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR. THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, FOR CONTINUING
TO TALK. COLLEAGUES, ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS OR CONCERNS?
I HEAR? I SEE SENATOR GROVE.
SENATOR GROVE THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. I MY APOLOGIES, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND CHAIR. I WAS,
CHAIRING RULES, PRESENTING,
BALANCING HEALTH. SO I APOLOGIZE
THAT I WAS LATE, I, I APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATION THAT WE HAD
ABOUT THIS BILL. I THINK ALL OF
US HAD SIMILAR STORIES TO SHARE
DURING COVID A FEW YEARS AGO, I
THINK YOU HAVE APPROACHED THIS
IN A VERY THOUGHTFUL MANNER,
GIVING OUR PUBLIC SAFETY PEOPLE
OR, EXCUSE ME, OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
PEOPLE, INDIVIDUALS OR DIRECTORS
, TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
THAT THEY HAVE. AND ALSO, IF THE
BILL IS PASSED THAT THEY HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO, REMEDY
SOMETHING IF SOMETHING IS
DESPERATELY NEEDS TO BE TAKEN
CARE OF. BUT I LISTENED TO SOME
OF THE OBJECTIONS OR READ SOME
OF THE OBJECTIONS AND, YOU KNOW,
AND I AND I LISTENED TO MY
ESTEEMED COLLEAGUE, NEXT TO ME,
AND I, I THINK THAT YOU'VE
APPROACHED THIS IN A VERY
THOUGHTFUL WAY. I UNDERSTAND
IT'S A TOUGH ISSUE TO COME, YOU
KNOW, TO COME TOGETHER ON. BUT
IT'S A VERY THOUGHTFUL WAY, I
THINK THERE'S ALWAYS A WAY WHERE
THERE'S A, YOU KNOW, WHERE
THERE'S A WILL, THERE'S A WAY IF
THERE'S A CONCERN WHICH THERE
VERY WELL COULD BE ABOUT OTHER
RESIDENTS, YOU COULD HAVE AN
ISOLATED ROOM WITH A SEPARATE
ENTRANCE. MOST PEOPLE HAVE THOSE
IN THOSE FACILITIES, WE HAD
SOMEBODY MEET IN A STAIRWELL ONE
TIME DURING COVID JUST TO, YOU
KNOW, PROVIDE THAT PERSON
COMFORT, THAT WAS ISOLATED. SO I
THINK THERE'S WHERE THERE'S A
WILL, THERE'S A WAY. AND I THINK
THAT, THE WAY YOU APPROACH THIS
BILL WAS VERY WELL BALANCED. AND
SO THANK YOU FOR THE
CONVERSATION. AND ANSWERING ALL
MY QUESTIONS THAT I HAD ON THE
PHONE CALL THE OTHER DAY.
APPRECIATED. AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR
GROVE. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS? I DON'T
SEE ANY, IT'S A VERY DIFFICULT
ISSUE. I APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT YOU TOOK THE TIME TO COME
AND PRESENT YOUR VIEWS VERY,
VERY INFORMATIVE. SO THANK YOU.
SO, MEMBER, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE, THANK YOU AGAIN.
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION. I
THINK THIS WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH A GOAL, IT'S NOT
ALWAYS EASY. WE'VE ATTEMPTED
AGAIN OVER MONTHS NOW TO TRY TO
FIND A WAY TO ACHIEVE PUBLIC
HEALTH SAFETY, NOT A PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPERT. I ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT WE DO RELY ON THAT INPUT,
BUT, REALLY, IT WOULD BE HELPFUL
GOING FORWARD. IS TO TRY AND GET
TO THE TRY TO GET TO. YES. I
ALWAYS TRY TO GET TO YES ON MY
COLLEAGUES AND THEIR BILLS. AND
WHEN THERE'S QUESTIONS AND, AND
I KIND OF NEED, THIS TO MOVE
ALONG TO BE ABLE TO HOPEFULLY
MESSAGE THAT WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO, TO REACH THAT
COMMON GROUND, TO ENSURE THAT
THIS HAPPENS AT THE AT THE END
OF THE DAY, WE LEARNED A LOT OF
LESSONS FROM COVID. I DO THINK
WE SHOULD REMEMBER THAT ERA, BUT
WE SHOULD ALSO NOT CONTINUE. WE
SHOULD LEARN FROM IT. AND I
THINK THAT'S WHAT THE INTENT OF
THIS CONVERSATION WAS THROUGH
THE WORKING GROUP THAT WAS
FORMED, THEY LEARNED FROM THOSE
MISTAKES AND THEY LEARNED FROM
WHAT WORKED WELL AND THE
LEGISLATION BEFORE YOU IS
REFLECTIVE OF THAT. AND FOR THAT
REASON, I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
WHEN APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. I JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT YOU'VE TAKEN A VERY
PROFESSIONAL APPROACH TO THE WAY
THAT YOU HAVE MANAGED THIS BILL.
I'VE APPRECIATED THAT. YOU
OBVIOUSLY HEARD SOME CONCERNS
FROM SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES AND
SOME OF THOSE WHO HAVE PRESENTED
TODAY. I ASK YOU TO IF SHOULD
THE BILL MOVE FORWARD, I ASK
THAT YOU CONTINUE TO ENGAGE IN
CONVERSATIONS NOT ONLY WITH MY
COLLEAGUES, BUT WITH THOSE ON ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE ISSUE TO SEE
WHERE WE GO. WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM. AS SOON AS WE DO GET A
QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE A MOTION AND
WE'LL TAKE A VOTE ON THE BILL.
AND AGAIN, THANK YOU. AND THANK
YOU ALL FOR PRESENTING. LET'S
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
MEDI-CAL. TELEHEALTH PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN READY. THANK YOU.
NØ. THANK YOU. OH, COME ON,
SHANNON, STICK IT UP. THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US. GREAT. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. SENATORS.
WHEN I AUTHORED AB 32 IN 2022,
MY CLEAR INTENT WAS TO INCREASE
PATIENT CHOICE AND ACCESS TO
CARE VIA ALL FORMS OF TELEHEALTH
SERVICES FOR PEOPLE, REGARDLESS
OF THE TYPE OF HEALTH INSURANCE.
CURRENTLY, PEOPLE WITH PRIVATE
INSURANCE BENEFIT FROM INSURANCE
POLICIES THAT COVER ALL
TELEHEALTH SERVICES EQUALLY,
INCLUDING MOBILE APPS, THROUGH
ASYNCHRONOUS MESSAGING. THESE
APPS ARE IMPORTANT BECAUSE
WORKING FAMILIES CAN ACCESS
MEDICAL CARE ON THEIR OWN
SCHEDULE WITHOUT HAVING TO TAKE
TIME AWAY FROM WORK OR THEIR
FAMILIES. HOWEVER, CURRENT
MEDI-CAL POLICIES RESTRICT
ASYNCRONOUS TELEHEALTH OPTIONS
FOR THEIR BENEFICIARIES TO ONLY
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES, WHICH
CREATES BARRIERS TO EQUITABLE
CARE. THIS PARTICULARLY IMPACTS
THE ABILITY FOR MEDI-CAL
BENEFICIARIES TO ACCESS
SENSITIVE SERVICES LIKE
REPRODUCTIVE AND MENTAL HEALTH
CARE, THAT CAN BE APPROPRIATELY
PROVIDED USING A ASYNCRONOUS.
MODALITIES LIKE APPS, AB 2339
WOULD EXPAND ACCESS TO SENSITIVE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES THAT CAN BE
PROVIDED USING ASYNCRONOUS
MODALITIES FOR MEDI-CAL
BENEFICIARIES, ALLOWING MEDI-CAL
BENEFICIARIES TO ACCESS THIS
FORM OF CARE WILL PROVIDE EQUAL
ACCESS TO ASYNCRONOUS TELEHEALTH
SERVICES AND GIVE MEDI-CAL
BENEFICIARIES THE SAME
CONVENIENT CARE AS THEIR PEERS
WITH PRIVATE INSURANCE. WITH ME
TODAY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IS MAI FLEMING, MD, FAAFP,
ASSISTANT CLINICAL PROFESSOR AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FAMILY AND
COMMUNITY MEDICINE AT UCSF, AND
MOLLY ROBINSON ROBINSON, A VICE
PRESIDENT OF GOVERNMENTAL
AFFAIRS FOR PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA. WELCOME TO YOU BOTH.
THANKS FOR JOINING US. PLEASE
PROCEED. PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELVES FOR THE RECORD.
FIRST, THOUGH. I WANT TO PULL
THAT A LITTLE CLOSER. OKAY THE
LAST SPEAKER DECIDED TO MOVE IT
TO THE MIDDLE. HELLO. GOOD
AFTERNOON. I'M CHAIR ROTH AND
HEALTH COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS DOCTOR MAI FLEMING. I AM
A FAMILY MEDICINE PHYSICIAN WITH
UCSF WHO PROVIDES MEDICATION,
ABORTION VIA TELEHEALTH WITH.
HEY, JANE, I'M HERE TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. SO
HERE IN CALIFORNIA, A STATE THAT
IS PROUD TO BE A REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM STATE, ABOUT A THIRD OF
OUR COUNTIES STILL DO NOT HAVE A
SINGLE ABORTION PROVIDER,
LEAVING THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
WITHOUT A LOCAL OPTION WHEN IN
NEED OF ABORTION CARE. THIS GAP
IS CURRENTLY BEING MET BY
TELEMEDICINE PROVIDERS LIKE ME,
WHO HAVE BEEN ABLE TO REACH
PATIENTS IN EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THOSE COUNTIES, INCLUDING ALL OF
THE MOST RURAL COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS MEANS THAT
THOSE PATIENTS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
ACCESS CRITICAL REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE WITHOUT NEEDING TO
TRAVEL HOURS OR HUNDREDS OF
MILES AWAY TO THE NEAREST CLINIC
. FOR SOME PARTICULARLY YOUNG
PEOPLE, PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
REPRODUCTIVE COERCION, PEOPLE
WHO CANNOT TAKE TIME AWAY FROM
THEIR JOBS OR TO FIND CHILDCARE,
FINDING THE TIME, SPACE, SAFETY
AND PRIVACY EVEN FOR A
SYNCHRONOUS TELEMEDICINE VISIT,
LET ALONE FOR AN IN-PERSON
VISIT, CAN BE AN IMPOSSIBLE TASK
, ESPECIALLY FOR A SENSITIVE
SERVICE LIKE ABORTION CARE. IN
ASYNCRONOUS CARE, WE ASK ALL THE
SAME QUESTIONS ÓRDENES ORDER ALL
THE SAME MEDICALLY INDICATED
TESTING AND PROVIDE THE SAME
HIGH STANDARD OF CARE WITH A
ROBUST, MULTIDISCIPLINARY TEAM
OF PHYSICIANS, ADVANCED PRACTICE
CLINICIANS, NURSES, JUST THE
SAME AS WE WOULD WITH EITHER
IN-PERSON CARE OR SYNCHRONOUS
TELEMEDICINE CARE, AND FOR SOME
PEOPLE, THE ONLY VIABLE OPTION
FOR FOLKS WITHOUT NEEDING TO
INTERRUPT THEIR BUSY DAILY LIVES
IS GETTING CARE VIA ASYNCRONOUS
CARE. ASYNCRONOUS TELEMEDICINE.
ABORTION CARE, SPECIFICALLY HAS
BEEN VIGOROUSLY STUDIED AND HAS
BEEN FOUND TO BE JUST AS SAFE
AND EFFECTIVE AND ACCEPTABLE AS
IN-PERSON CARE, INCLUDING ONE
STUDY THAT WAS PUBLISHED BY THE
AMERICAN JOURNAL OF PUBLIC
HEALTH JUST THIS YEAR, SHOWING
THAT PATIENTS ACTUALLY FELT MORE
CARED FOR WITH ASYNCRONOUS CARE
THAN SYNCHRONOUS CARE WITHIN
THIS WITHIN THIS CARE, AND MY
PATIENTS NEARLY UNIVERSALLY
EXPRESS GRATITUDE FOR HAVING
THIS CARE MODALITY AVAILABLE,
DETAILING HOW CONVENIENT IT WAS,
HOW THEY DIDN'T KNOW IF, HOW, OR
EVEN WHETHER THEY WOULD BE ABLE
TO ACCESS THIS ABORTION CARE
WITHOUT THIS OPTION AVAILABLE,
WHERE I PRACTICE CARE, WE
ACTUALLY OFFER THE OPTION OF
DOING SYNCHRONOUS CARE OR
ASYNCHRONOUS CARE IN LESS THAN
1% OF OUR PATIENTS ACTUALLY EVEN
CHOOSE SYNCHRONOUS CARE, 99%
PREFER ASYNCHRONOUS CARE. BUT
THIS CONVENIENT, SAFE, AND FOR
SOME NECESSARY OPTION IS NOT
AVAILABLE TO THOSE WHO MAY HAVE
THE HIGHEST NEED. BECAUSE, AS IT
STANDS, MEDI-CAL PROHIBITS ME
FROM USING ASYNCHRONOUS CARE TO
ESTABLISH A PATIENT PROVIDER
RELATIONSHIP WITH MY PATIENTS.
NEARLY ONE THIRD OF THE PATIENTS
ACCESSING OUR SERVICES REPORT AN
INCOME OF LESS THAN $20,000 A
YEAR, BELOW THE INCOME LIMIT. TO
QUALIFY FOR MEDI-CAL. SO THAT
MEANS THAT THOUSANDS OF THE
LOWEST INCOME PATIENTS ARE BEING
BARRED BY CALIFORNIA FROM BEING
ABLE TO USE THEIR INSURANCE TO
RECEIVE CARE FROM ME IN THE
MODALITY THAT THEY NEED, OR ELSE
FORCING THEM TO SURMOUNT
ADDITIONAL BARRIERS TO ATTEND A
SENSITIVE SYNCHRONOUS
TELEMEDICINE OR AN IN-PERSON
VISIT. ADDITIONALLY, MY PATIENTS
WHO ACCESS ASYNCHRONOUS CARE ARE
OFTEN ABLE TO RECEIVE THE CARE
THAT THEY NEED WITHIN DAYS OF
FINDING OUT THAT THEY ARE
PREGNANT, A TIME FRAME THAT IS
UNHEARD OF IN IN-PERSON CARE OR
EVEN SYNCHRONOUS TELEMEDICINE
CARE, AND A TIME FRAME THAT
EVERYBODY, REGARDLESS OF THEIR
INSURANCE, SHOULD BE ABLE TO
ACCESS. AB 2339 WOULD ENABLE
PATIENTS COVERED BY MEDI-CAL,
THOSE WHO ALREADY FACE SOME OF
THE HIGHEST BARRIERS TO CARE TO
ACCESS THIS TIMELY, ASYNCHRONOUS
TELEMEDICINE CARE AND ELIMINATE
THE BARRIERS THAT I'VE
PERSONALLY SEEN WITH SYNCHRONOUS
AND ÁP IN-PERSON CARE. EVERYBODY
DESERVES TO ACT AS CARE IN THE
WAY THAT BEST SUITS THEIR
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS, AND
CIRCUMSTANCES, AND THAT INCLUDES
PEOPLE WHO ARE PUBLICLY INSURED,
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND ALL
OF YOU AS AS THE REPRESENTATIVE
OF THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE HERE,
NEED TO STAND TRUE TO ITS
PROMISE AS A REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM STATE AND NOT BE WHAT
STANDS IN THE WAY OF PEOPLE
ACCESSING EQUITABLE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE. BY VOTING YES ON
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
DOCTOR. THANKS FOR JOINING US.
YES, MA'AM. HI. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR ROTH AND MEMBERS MOLLY
ROBSON WITH PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA,
REPRESENTING SEVEN AFFILIATES
THAT PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE
SEXUAL AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE, GENDER AFFIRMING CARE, AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. WHEN COVID
BEGAN FOUR YEARS AGO, PLANNED
PARENTHOOD QUICKLY MOVED TO
IMPLEMENT A SECURE TELEHEALTH
APPOINTMENTS FOR SENSITIVE
SERVICES LIKE BIRTH CONTROL, STI
TREATMENT, PREGNANCY COUNSELING,
PREP AND PEP, AND GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE. TODAY,
TELEHEALTH CONTINUES TO BE A
POPULAR CHOICE FOR PLANNED
PARENTHOOD PATIENTS, EVEN WHEN
IN-PERSON APPOINTMENTS ARE
AVAILABLE, OUR PATIENTS CONTINUE
TO HAVE THE CHOICE TO ACCESS
CRUCIAL SERVICES VIA TELEHEALTH
WITHOUT HAVING TO WORRY ABOUT
THE ADDITIONAL TIME AND
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO MAKE AN
IN-PERSON APPOINTMENT. MORE THAN
1 MILLION MEDI-CAL PATIENTS ARE
SEEN BY PLANNED PARENTHOOD
PROVIDERS EACH YEAR, COMPRISING
80% OF ALL PLANNED PARENTHOOD
PATIENTS IN CALIFORNIA. IN
SERVING A PATIENT POPULATION
THAT IS DISPROPORTIONATELY LOW
INCOME AND HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED, PLANNED PARENTHOOD
STRONGLY BELIEVES THAT
TELEHEALTH, INCLUDING
ASYNCRONOUS TELEHEALTH, IS
CRITICAL TO ADDRESS THE HEALTH
INEQUITIES AND IMPROVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE SERVICES FOR THIS
POPULATION. THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE MEDI-CAL PATIENTS HAVE
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
THROUGH THE SAME OPTIONS
AFFORDED TO COMMERCIALLY INSURED
PATIENTS. ESTABLISH CONSISTENCY
IN STATE LAW WITH EXISTING
PROTECTIONS FOR SYNCHRONOUS
TELEHEALTH, AND PRESERVE A
PATIENT'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE A NEW
PROVIDER FOR SENSITIVE SERVICES
VIA ASYNCRONOUS TELEHEALTH
PLATFORMS. I RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL
TODAY. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR JOINING US. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ONLY ON
THE MEASURE. PLEASE YES, SIR.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS.
DAVID GONZALEZ, ON BEHALF OF
AMERICA'S PHYSICIAN GROUPS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. VANESSA KHN ON
THE CALF ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANKS NEXT, MARTIN RADOSEVICH,
ON BEHALF OF REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM FOR ALL CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. YES, MA'AM.
SARAH BRIDGE, ON BEHALF OF HYMNS
AND HERS IN SUPPORT. LIBBY
SANCHEZ, ON BEHALF OF ALTAMED IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. CRAIG
PULSIPHER, ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA, IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ABBY ALVAREZ WITH LEADING
AGE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT? NOW LET'S TURN TO
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION. ANY
LEAD WITNESSES FIRST. ANY
OTHERS? ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE. LET'S
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
DESK. COLLEAGUES, ANY QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS? LINES. I
SEEING NONE. SO REMEMBER, IT'S
YOUR LUCKY DAY. YOU COULD CLOSE.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S LUCKY DAY.
I'D LIKE TO HAVE THIS DONE. YOU
KNOW, SENATORS, LET ME JUST BE
CLEAR. THIS THIS BILL DOES NOT
CHANGE AND CERTAINLY DOES NOT
WEAKEN THE RIGHT FOR IN-PERSON,
CARE HEALTH CARE FOR MEDI-CAL
BENEFICIARIES, IT'S JUST
REQUIRING EXISTING LAW REQUIRES
ANY TECHNOLOGY USED FOR
ASYNCHRONOUS TELEHEALTH TO BE
SECURE AND CONFIDENTIAL. AND
THAT IS ALWAYS WITH A LICENSED
HEALTH PROVIDER. MANY MODERN
HEALTH SYSTEMS ALREADY HAVE
SECURE MOBILE APPLICATIONS FOR
PATIENT COMMUNICATION AND
ELECTRONIC DATA TRANSMISSION.
THIS BILL SIMPLY CONFORMS THE
COVERAGE OF APP BASED TELEHEALTH
SERVICES FOR CALIFORNIANS ON
MEDI-CAL, WITH THOSE THAT HAVE
PRIVATE INSURANCE. YOU KNOW,
ESSENTIALLY WHAT YOU'RE VOTING
ON TODAY IS WHETHER OR NOT
MEDI-CAL BENEFICIARIES CAN HAVE
THE SAME ACCESS TO SENSITIVE
SERVICES THAT YOU ALL HAVE WITH
YOUR PRIVATE HEALTH INSURANCE
PROVIDER TODAY. FURTHER, THIS
BILL ALIGNS WITH CALIFORNIA'S
EMPHASIS ON PATIENT CHOICE AND
TELEHEALTH, AND FURTHER
STATEWIDE EFFORTS TO EXPAND
ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE AND
MENTAL HEALTH CARE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, MA'AM, THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US. AS SOON AS
WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM, WE'LL
TAKE A MOTION AND WE WILL TAKE A
VOTE. WE APPRECIATE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, IT'S NEXT,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOWE IS DECIDED
TO ALLOW DOCTOR WOOD TO PROCEED
NEXT. SO WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
ITEM NUMBER 17, ASSEMBLY BILL
2749, CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFIT
EXCHANGE. FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE.
NEXT. DOCTOR WOOD, PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN READY.
FIRST OF ALL, I THANK TO. THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE AGAIN. MUCH
APPRECIATED AND THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. SO I'D LIKE
TO START BY THANKING YOU AND THE
MR. CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL IN
RECENT YEARS, CALIFORNIA HAS
MADE ENORMOUS STRIDES TOWARDS
BOTH UNIVERSAL HEALTH COVERAGE
AND LABOR RELATIONS. IN 2022, I
AUTHORED AB 2530, WHICH COVERED
WHICH REQUIRED COVERED
CALIFORNIA TO ADMINISTER A
PROGRAM FOR WORKERS WHO LOSE
HEALTH INSURANCE COVERAGE DUE TO
A LABOR DISPUTE. UNDER THIS
PROGRAM, THOSE CONSUMERS WOULD
RECEIVE THE SAME PREMIUM AND
COST SHARING ASSISTANCE AS A
CONSUMER WITH WHOSE HOUSEHOLD
INCOME IS AT 138.1% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL. DURING
THE FIRST YEAR OF AB 2530,
IMPLEMENT THÀNH, IT WAS
DISCOVERED THAT FURTHER
CLARIFICATION IS NEEDED IN THE
LANGUAGE. LABOR DISPUTES,
PARTICULARLY IN LARGE
INDUSTRIES, CAN BE COMPLEX AND
AFFECTS SURROUNDING EMPLOYERS
AND WORKERS. THIS PROPOSAL
CLARIFIES ELIGIBILITY FOR THE
PROGRAM TO REACH THE INTENDED
TARGET OF WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS
WHO ARE DIRECTLY INVOLVED IN THE
STRIKE. I ALSO PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL CLARIFICATIONS AND
CHANGES TO THE LAW THAT WILL
BETTER ENABLE COVERED CALIFORNIA
TO IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM AND
ENSURE BENEFITS OF THIS
IMPORTANT PROGRAM ARE
ADMINISTERED EFFECTIVELY TO
WORKERS WHO NEED THEM. HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS BETH
CAPELL REPRESENTED, REPRESENTING
A COALITION OF LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS, INCLUDING
TEAMSTERS AND UNITE HERE AND
HERE, TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS IS KELLY GREEN,
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNICATIONS AND
EXTERNAL AFFAIRS FOR COVERED
CALIFORNIA. WELCOME TO YOU BOTH.
PLEASE PROCEED MORNING OR
AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
BETH CAPELL, ON BEHALF OF
TEAMSTERS AND UNITE HERE. AND AS
A COURTESY, THE UFCW AND SEIU AS
WELL, AND WITH MANY OTHER,
SUPPORTERS, WE'RE HERE IN
SUPPORT. WE'RE ALSO HERE TO
REPORT THAT THE EARLIER
LEGISLATION WE HAVE HAPPY THINGS
TO REPORT. IT WAS IMPLEMENTED
QUICKLY AND EFFECTIVELY BY
COVERED CALIFORNIA, WENT INTO
EFFECT ON JULY 1ST OF LAST YEAR.
AND IN AUGUST, THERE WAS A
STRIKE OF A TEAMSTER UNIT DOWN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY, WHERE THEY
LOST HEALTH BENEFITS AND COVERED
CALIFORNIA'S SCRAMBLED
IMMEDIATELY AND GOT THEM THE
COVERAGE THEY WERE OBLIGATED TO
PROVIDE UNDER THE LAW. IN
WORKING THROUGH LAST YEAR, BOTH
THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY
STRIKE THAT AFFECTED SO MANY AND
ALSO THE POTENTIAL OF A
TEAMSTERS UPS STRIKE THAT WOULD
HAVE AFFECTED MORE THAN 40,000
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES. WE FOUND
THAT THE LAW NEEDED ADDITIONAL
CLARIFICATION AND THE BILL YOU
HAVE BEFORE YOU REPRESENTS THE
DECISIONS WE MADE, ALONG WITH
COVERED CALIFORNIA OVER THE
COURSE OF THE YEAR IN ATTEMPTING
TO IMPLEMENT THE LAW. I WOULD
ALSO REMIND THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
ON THE BUDGET COMMITTEE THAT
THERE IS A PENDING BUDGET
REQUEST TO ASSURE THAT IF WE ARE
IN A SITUATION SIMILAR TO A
TEAMSTER UPS STRIKE WITH TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF AFFECTED
CALIFORNIANS, THAT THERE WILL BE
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES REYES TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF ALL THOSE
CALIFORNIANS. AND WITH THAT,
THANK YOU, AND WE'RE PLEASED TO
BE HERE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION, ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. MEGAN
SUPERS, ON BEHALF OF THE WRITERS
GUILD OF AMERICA WEST AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE
. YVONNE FERNANDEZ, CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. YES,
MA'AM. JANICE O'MALLEY WITH
AFSCME CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT? WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE?
FIRST, ANY LEAD WITNESSES? ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION?
SEEING NONE. LET'S BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE DESK.
COLLEAGUES, ANY QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS? SEEING
NONE. DOCTOR, WOULD YOU MAY
CLOSE JUST RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE WHEN YOU GET A
QUORUM AND I FEEL YOUR PAIN ON
THAT. AS SOON AS WE GET A
QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE A MOTION. AND
WE WILL DO JUST THAT, SIR. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION. THANK
YOU. MEMBERS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOWE, ITEM NUMBER FIVE, AB 2132,
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. GOOD TO
SEE YOU BACK, SIR. NICE TIE.
THANK YOU MUCH. PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN READY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR. CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES. HAPPY
PRIDE. GOOD TO SEE EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF YOU. AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 2132,
WHICH OF COURSE HELPS TO ENSURE
THAT WE'RE TACKLING THE
UNFORTUNATE RISE OF TUBERCULOSIS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. VÀ
BY REQUESTING THAT PHYSICIANS
THEN OAN HELP TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE BY REQUESTING THAT OF
OFFERING, TB SCREENING TESTS,
WHICH, OF COURSE, WILL HELP TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE TACKLING THIS
ISSUE OF RISING CASES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I HAVE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT, AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SIR. PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY.
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR
THE RECORD, THOUGH, I HAVE TO
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
HEALTH COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
PRIYANKA MANGHANI AND I'M A
PUBLIC HEALTH PROFESSIONAL AND
EPIDEMIOLOGIST. HAVING WORKED ON
TB AND HIV CONTROL ACROSS INDIA,
AFRICA AND ON U.S. AID AND CDC
FUNDED PROJECTS. I'M ALSO A
TUBERCULOSIS SURVIVOR, AND I
WISH TO LEVERAGE MY PERSONAL
JOURNEY AND EXPERTISE TO PIONEER
INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS AIMING TO
ERADICATE INFECTIOUS DISEASES
AND TRANSFORM LIVES. IF WE WERE
TO EXCLUDE COVID 19 DATA, TB IS
THE DEADLIEST INFECTIOUS DISEASE
WORLDWIDE AND KILLS EVERY
SOMEONE, EVERY 20S CALIFORNIANS
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
BY TUBERCULOSIS, WITH AN
ESTIMATED 2 MILLION CALIFORNIANS
INFECTED WITH TB. OF THESE 2
MILLION CALIFORNIANS, ONLY 23%
ARE AWARE OF THEIR INFECTION AND
ONLY 13% HAVE BEEN TREATED. WE
HAVE DOUBLED THE RATE AS
COMPARED TO THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
SEEN IN THE UNITED STATES. TB IS
UNDERDIAGNOSED, LATENT
TUBERCULOSIS INFECTION CAN
HARBOR ITSELF IN A PATIENT'S
BODY FOR DECADES, SUCH AS 20 TO
30 YEARS WITHOUT SYMPTOMS, AND
MANY PEOPLE THUS WILL NOT KNOW
THAT THEY HAVE AN INFECTION
UNTIL IT IS TOO LATE.
FURTHERMORE, PEOPLE WITH LATENT
TB INFECTION DO NOT HAVE
SYMPTOMS AND THEY CANNOT SPREAD
TB BACTERIA TO OTHERS. HOWEVER,
THE LATENT TB BACTERIA CAN
BECOME ACTIVE IN THE BODY AND
MULTIPLY AND IN THAT CASE, THE
PERSON WILL GO FROM HAVING A
LATENT TB INFECTION TO BEING
SICK WITH ACTIVE TUBERCULOSIS
DISEASE, WHICH IS A PROBABILITY
SEEN IN 10 TO 15% OF THE CASES.
AND FOR THIS PURPOSE, IT'S
CRUCIAL THAT PEOPLE WITH LATENT
TB INFECTION SHOULD BE TREATED
SO AS TO PREVENT THEM FROM
DEVELOPING AN ACTIVE TB DISEASE.
AS A TB SURVIVOR, I CANNOT
STRESS ENOUGH THE IMPORTANCE OF
TESTING AND TIMELY TREATMENT. I
WAS DIAGNOSED WITH ACTIVE TB AND
INITIALLY HAD NO SYMPTOMS
BESIDES WEIGHT LOSS, WHICH
FURTHER DEVELOPED INTO CHEST
PAIN. THIS LED TO A COMPLICATED
DIAGNOSIS SINCE I HAD NO
PRODUCTIVE COUGH TO EVEN DO A
SPUTUM TEST. I WAS FINALLY
DIAGNOSED ON THE BASIS OF A CT
SCAN WHICH SHOWED ACTIVE TB
INFECTION ON POST, WHICH I
COMPLETED MY ENTIRE TREATMENT
AND WAS DECLARED TB FREE. AFTER
NINE MONTHS OF DAILY ADHERENCE
TO MY MEDICATIONS, ADHERENCE TO
TB MEDICATIONS IS HIGHLY CRUCIAL
AS POOR ADHERENCE CAN PROMOTE
THE EMERGENCE OF MULTI-DRUG
RESISTANT TB. IT CAN ALSO
PROMOTE PROLONGED INFECTIOUSNESS
AND POOR TREATMENT OUTCOMES, AS
WELL AS DEATH, WHICH HAS BEEN
SEEN IN VARIOUS TB ENDEMIC
ZONES. WHERE I HAVE WORKED IN TB
KILLS, MORE THAN 200
CALIFORNIANS EACH YEAR, THE
PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE WITH TB WHO
HAVE BEEN DYING HAS BEEN
INCREASING. IN THE YEAR 2021,
217 PEOPLE WITH TB DIED. THAT IS
12% OF THE TB CASES OF THESE 61
PEOPLE, THAT IS, 28% DIED EVEN
BEFORE RECEIVING TREATMENT FOR
TB. WE'VE ALSO SEEN THAT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF TB CASES, WHICH
IS 85, HAVE BEEN ATTRIBUTABLE TO
PROGRESSION OF A LATENT TB
INFECTION TO ACTIVE TB IN 2023.
THERE WERE EIGHT NEW TB
OUTBREAKS AND 13 OUTBREAKS ARE
CURRENTLY ONGOING. IN 14
JURISDICTIONS, EACH INVOLVING AT
LEAST FOUR PERSONS. RECENTLY, WE
SAW THAT THE CITY OF LONG BEACH
AND CALIFORNIA IN MAY 2024
DECLARED A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY DUE TO AN OUTBREAK OF
TUBERCULOSIS, WHICH HAD 14
ACTIVE TB CASES, NINE
HOSPITALIZATION, AS WELL AS ONE
DEATH. AND THERE WERE 170 PEOPLE
EXPOSED. THESE SPIKES CAN BE
ATTRIBUTED TO THE BACTERIA LYING
DORMANT FOR YEARS BEFORE
BECOMING DEADLY, WHICH MEANS
THAT WE HAD 20 TO 30 YEARS WHERE
WE COULD HAVE EASILY HELPED
THESE PATIENTS GET RID OF THEIR
TB INFECTIONS. THE MEDICAL AND
SOCIETAL COSTS OF TUBERCULOSIS
REACHED $265 MILLION FOR
CALIFORNIA IN THE YEAR 2023.
THIS ALSO HIGH BURDEN OF TB IN
PATIENTS WITH DIABETES END STAGE
RENAL DISEASE, HIV INFECTION, AS
WELL AS HEPATITIS C WITH PEOPLE
LIVING WITH HIV ARE 16 TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO FALL ILL WITH TB
THAN AS COMPARED TO THOSE
WITHOUT HIV INFECTION, AND TB IS
KNOWN TO BE THE LEADING CAUSE OF
DEATH IN PEOPLE INFECTED WITH
HIV. ADDITIONALLY POPULATIONS
LIKE ASIAN AMERICAN, PACIFIC
ISLANDERS, LATINO, BLACK AS WELL
AS HOMELESS POPULATIONS ARE AT A
HIGHER RISK FOR TUBERCULOSIS.
FOR LATENT TUBERCULOSIS
INFECTION, WE CAN'T AFFORD TO
MAKE THIS MISTAKE ANYMORE. THIS
IS AN ISSUE OF HEALTH EQUITY. AB
232 WOULD GIVE THESE 1.5 MILLION
CALIFORNIANS A CHANCE TO BECOME
AWARE OF THEIR INFECTIONS AND
MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT
THEIR HEALTH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
WAS ALMOST FIVE MINUTES, SO THAT
WAS FINE. WE NEED THE
PRESENTATION, SO I'D ASK YOU TO
MOVE IT ALONG. THANK YOU. SURE.
USE YOURS IS EQUALLY VALUABLE.
SO IT IS, BUT I WILL BE ON THE
BREVITY SIDE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OUR BOARD MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE. MY NAME
IS MICHAEL CARSON. I AM THE
RETIRED ORANGE COUNTY
TUBERCULOSIS PROGRAM MANAGER,
AND I AM PAST PRESIDENT AND
CURRENT MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
TB CONTROLLERS ASSOCIATION AND A
TUBERCULOSIS ELIMINATION
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. IN 2016,
DURING MY TENURE AS CALIFORNIA
TB CONTROLLERS ASSOCIATION
PRESIDENT, WE WORKED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO ISSUE A SCIENTIFICALLY
BASED PROVIDER PILOTED TOOL AND
USER'S GUIDE FOR TB RISK
ASSESSMENT AND GUIDANCE FOR
LATENT TB INFECTION, OR LTBI
TESTING IN SEPTEMBER OF 2016,
THE UNITED STATES PREVENTIVE
SERVICES TASK FORCE ISSUED
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR LTBI TESTING
IN PRIMARY CARE FACILITIES. IN
2017, ORANGE COUNTY CONDUCTED A
STUDY PUBLISHED IN 2022 THAT
FOUND INTERVENTIONS INCLUDING
ADOPTION OF A STANDARDIZED TB
RISK ASSESSMENT PROVIDER
TRAINING AND USE OF A CARE
COORDINATOR CAN HELP INCREASE
LTBI SCREENING, TESTING, AND
TREATMENT IN COMMUNITY CLINICS.
BEFORE THIS BILL WAS EVEN
CONCEIVED, CDPH CONDUCTED A
MODELING STUDY PUBLISHED IN 2020
THAT SIMULATED THE EXACT
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL. THE
STUDY FOUND THAT HYPOTHETICAL
TESTING AND TREATMENTS WITH 100%
ADHERENCE TO EITHER THE USPSTF
OR CDPH TOOL TESTING
RECOMMENDATIONS, WOULD RESULT IN
A 40% DECLINE IN ACTIVE TB CASES
AND A 45% DECLINE IN LTBI
PREVALENCE WITHIN THE FIRST TEN
YEARS OF IMPLEMENTATION. EVEN
TESTING 25% OF ELIGIBLE PATIENTS
DURING PRIMARY CARE ENCOUNTERS
WOULD RESULT IN A 30% DECLINE IN
CASES FROM BASELINE LEVELS.
BASED ON CURRENT SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE, THE CALIFORNIA ADULT
TB RISK ASSESSMENT AND USER'S
GUIDE WERE UPDATED IN 2024. THIS
RISK ASSESSMENT AND THE GUIDE
FOR MEDICAL PROVIDERS TO PREVENT
TB IN FOUR STEPS, PLUS OTHER
PROVIDER RESOURCES AND TOOLS,
ARE CURRENTLY AVAILABLE ON THE
CDPH, TB FREE CALIFORNIA .ORG
WEBSITE. AB 2132 WOULD NOT ONLY
EMPOWER PROVIDERS AND PATIENTS
TO BRING TB TO THE FOREFRONT OF
HEALTH, BUT ALSO ALLOW COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS DOING TB
OUTREACH TO CONDUCT MUCH MORE
ROBUST WORK IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE ONLY PLEASE. THANK YOU,
DYLAN ELLIOTT, ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. KELLY BROOKS, ON BEHALF
OF THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OF
SANTA CLARA COUNTY HERE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. YES, MA'AM.
KATHY BERG, HEALTH OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA, IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. YES, SIR.
GEOFF NEAL, REPRESENTING THE
COUNTY OF CONTRA COSTA, ALSO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT? ANY OTHER WITNESSES?
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION?
LET'S START WITH LEAD WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION FEEL FREE TO TAKE
THE TABLE IF YOU'D LIKE. MR.
CHAIR, I'LL BE 20S, SO GIVE YOU
SOME TIME BACK. MARVIN PINEDA,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PRIMARY CARE ASSOCIATION, WE
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS, FOR THE PROGRESS THEY
MADE ON THE BILL, WE CONTINUE TO
OPPOSE, UNLESS AMENDED, DUE TO
THE MANDATE, WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
SPONSORS AND THE AUTHOR TO
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION WITNESSES? SEEING
NONE. LET'S BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE DAIS. QUESTIONS?
SENATOR GONZALEZ, I JUST WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. YOU MENTIONED LONG
BEACH AND UNFORTUNATELY, HAVING
AN OUTBREAK. THIS IS ABSOLUTELY,
MUCH NEEDED. SO I DON'T THINK WE
HAVE A QUORUM, BUT AT THE TIME
WE DO. I'LL BE HAPPY TO MOTION.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLYMAN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. PLEASE REMIND ME,
SENATOR, THANKS FOR YOUR
COMMENTS. ANY OTHER COMMENTS?
QUESTIONS, CONCERNS. SEEING NONE
. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE, YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
CHAIR. AND I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT A RECENT LA TIMES
ARTICLE ON MARCH 25TH
HIGHLIGHTING THAT THE HEADLINE
OF THIS ARTICLE IS TUBERCULOSIS
CASES RISING IN CALIFORNIA AND
STATE OFFICIALS ARE SOUNDING THE
ALARM. THIS, OF COURSE, IS
IMPORTANT AND IMPERATIVE THAT WE
HELP ADDRESS THIS ISSUE. I ALSO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE WORK AND
ACCEPTING COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
AS WELL, AND I ACTUALLY ASKED
FOR OUR VOTE. YOU READ MY MIND.
THANK YOU SIR. AS SOON AS WE GET
A QUORUM, WE WILL TAKE A MOTION
AND WE WILL DO JUST THAT. THANK
YOU TOO, FOR JOINING US. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY BILL
2258, HEALTH CARE COVERAGE, COST
SHARING. PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
READY. THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
MR. CHAIR, MEMBERS, FIRST I WANT
TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALL THEIR HARD
WORK. AND I ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED AMENDMENTS.
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB 2258,
WHICH IS SPONSORED BY INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA.
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA APLA HEALTH,
THE LOS ANGELES LGBT CENTER, AND
THE SAN FRANCISCO AIDS
FOUNDATION. A STUDY FOUND THAT A
$10 COST FOR HIV PREVENTION
MEDICATION DOUBLED PRESCRIPTION
ABANDONMENT RATES, INCREASING
THE POTENTIAL FOR HIV INFECTIONS
IN THESE PATIENTS. BARRIERS TO
PREVENTIVE CARE FORCE. PEOPLE TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN PREVENTING
EXPENSIVE AND DEVASTATING HEALTH
PROBLEMS BEFORE THEY OCCUR, AND
PUTTING FOOD ON THE TABLE. WHILE
WE DO HAVE PROTECTIONS FOR
PREVENTIVE CARE IN CALIFORNIA,
SOME OF THEM ARE BASED ON
FEDERAL PROTECTIONS, AND THERE'S
CONCERN THAT A RECENT COURT
CASES MAY PUT FEDERAL PREVENTIVE
SERVICE REQUIREMENTS ON WHICH
OUR STATE RELIES INTO INTO PERIL
. THAT IS WHY AB 2258 IS SO
IMPORTANT, AS IT WILL CODIFY IN
CALIFORNIA LAW EXISTING FEDERAL
GUIDANCE REQUIRING HEALTH PLANS
AND HEALTH INSURERS TO COVER
SERVICES THAT ARE INTEGRAL TO
THE DELIVERY OF RECOMMENDED
PREVENTIVE SERVICES WITHOUT OUT
OF OUT OF POCKET COSTS,
INCLUDING REVERSIBLE
CONTRACEPTIVES, PREP AND HIV,
AND OTHER STI SCREENINGS. IN
ESSENCE, THIS BILL IS ABOUT
ENSURING THAT LOW INCOME PEOPLE
HAVE ACCESS TO THE SAME
COMPREHENSIVE AND AFFORDABLE
PREVENTIVE HEALTH CARE AS
EVERYONE ELSE. FOR ME TODAY WITH
ME TODAY ARE CRAIG PULSIPHER,
REPRESENTING EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA, AND KATE FISHER FROM
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE, SPONSORS OF THE BILL
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION AND ASSISTS WITH
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SIR. PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN READY. OF COURSE.
IDENTIFY YOURSELVES. FOR THE
RECORD, GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, CRAIG PULSIPHER, ON
BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA,
PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF AB 2258,
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS,
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA AND THE
OTHER CO-SPONSORS OF THIS BILL,
HAVE ADVANCED AND SUPPORTED
NUMEROUS EFFORTS TO ENSURE THAT
LGBTQ AND ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCESS TO COMPREHENSIVE AND
AFFORDABLE PREVENTIVE HEALTH
CARE. THESE SERVICES INCLUDE
CRITICAL HEALTH INTERVENTIONS
SUCH AS SCREENINGS FOR LUNG AND
COLORECTAL CANCER, STATINS TO
PREVENT CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE,
AND PREP FOR HIV PREVENTION.
BECAUSE OF BOTH STATE AND
FEDERAL GUIDANCE UNDER THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT, HEALTH
PLANS ARE REQUIRED TO COVER NOT
ONLY THE PREVENTIVE SERVICES
THEMSELVES, BUT ALSO ALL OF THE
SERVICES THAT ARE INTEGRAL TO
PROVIDING THE PER THE
RECOMMENDED PREVENTIVE BENEFIT.
WITHOUT ANY PATIENT COST
SHARING. IN THE CASE OF PREP,
FOR EXAMPLE, THIS INCLUDES
REGULAR DOCTOR VISITS, HIV AND
STI SCREENING, AND OTHER LABS
THAT ARE AN INTEGRAL PART OF
ONGOING PREP CARE, IN LARGE PART
BECAUSE OF THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT, PREP IS NOW AVAILABLE AT NO
COST TO THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO NEED IT, AND
THIS REMAINS A CRITICAL PART OF
OUR ONGOING EFFORTS TO END THE
HIV EPIDEMIC IN CALIFORNIA.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE PROGRESS
WE'VE MADE TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
PREP AND OTHER PREVENTIVE
SERVICES IS CURRENTLY UNDER
THREAT. JUST LAST YEAR, A
FEDERAL JUDGE IN TEXAS STRUCK
DOWN KEY PROVISIONS OF THE ACA
REQUIRING HEALTH PLANS TO COVER
PREVENTIVE SERVICES AT NO COST.
AND WHILE THE CASE IS CURRENTLY
ON APPEAL, WE MUST ACT NOW TO
STRENGTHEN EXISTING LAW AND
PROTECT ACCESS TO THESE
PREVENTIVE SERVICES, REGARDLESS
OF WHAT HAPPENS IN THE COURTS,
IMPORTANTLY, AB 2258 WILL NOT
IMPOSE ANY NEW REQUIREMENTS ON
HEALTH PLANS. IT WILL SIMPLY
CODIFY EXISTING STATE AND
FEDERAL GUIDANCE TO ENSURE THAT
OUR LAWS ARE AS STRONG AS
POSSIBLE IN THE FACE OF ONGOING
ATTACKS ON THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT, APPRECIATE THE CELL MEMBERS
LEADERSHIP IN THIS SPACE AND
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. HI
KATIE FISHER, I'M AN ATTORNEY IN
THE HEALTH EQUITY AND ACCESS
OFFICE AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RICARDO LARA, WE'RE PROUD
CO-SPONSORS OF THE BILL. AND I
DON'T THINK I COULD SAY ANYTHING
BETTER THAN WHAT HAS ALREADY
BEEN SAID. SO I CAN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. BUT WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR BREVITY.
AND THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE,
BOTH OF YOU. WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT, PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELVES, STATE YOUR
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE ONLY, PLEASE. THANK YOU.
BECCA KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF OF
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU. VANESSA ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANKS FOR JOINING US. YES,
MA'AM. JENNIFER ROBLES WITH
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. THANKS LIBBY SANCHEZ,
ON BEHALF OF ALTAMED AND SUPPORT
. THANK YOU, MEGAN SUBERS, ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES LGBT
CENTER AND CPCA ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT. THANKS SANDRA POOLE ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT. THANKS
YES, SIR. MATT NAZARIAN WITH
SEIU CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ABBY ALVAREZ, ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO AIDS
FOUNDATION AND APPLE HEALTH IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? LEAD OPPOSITION.
WITNESS FREE TO JOIN US AT THE
TABLE OR MIKES. OKAY. MR. CHAIR
MEMBERS, STEPHANIE WATKINS, ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE, FIRST, WE'D LIKE TO
THANK THE WORK THE COMMITTEE HAS
DONE AND THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS, WE DID HAVE A CONCERN
NOT ON THE UNDERLYING PROPONENTS
OF THE BILL, BUT SPECIFICALLY TO
ENFORCEMENT LANGUAGE THAT WAS
ADDED. WE DID GET MORE CLARITY
FROM THE DEPARTMENT. SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT. AND ALSO THE
WORK THAT THE COMMITTEE DID ON
THE LANGUAGE WILL BE TAKING THAT
BACK TO OUR MEMBERS. BUT I THINK
OUR GENERAL, DISCUSSION ITEM
WOULD BE TO LOOK TOWARDS THE
DEPARTMENT, IF THERE IS
ADDITIONAL ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY
THAT'S NECESSARY, JUST IN
GENERAL IN THE INSURANCE CODE,
WE'D LIKE TO HAVE THAT AS A
BROADER CONVERSATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND POTENTIALLY A
STANDALONE BILL TO BE DISCUSSED
IN FUTURE REFERENCE. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR AND OTHER
INDIVIDUALS. OKAY. SEEING NO ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION,
SEEING NONE. THEN BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE DESK
COLLEAGUES, ANY COMMENTS,
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS? SEEING
NONE. SOME MEMBER YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. I WANT TO
THANK YOUR STAFF AGAIN AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME. AS SOON
AS WE FIND THE OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND ESTABLISH A QUORUM,
WE WILL TAKE A MOTION AND WE
WILL DO EXACTLY THAT. NICE
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR JOINING US.
SO WE.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH
WILL BE IN RECESS FOR FIVE
MINUTES.
QUORUM. FIRST, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR ROTH HERE. ROTH
HERE. NGUYEN HERE. NGUYEN HERE.
GLAZER GONZALEZ. SO USED TO THAT
GROVE. HURTADO. HURTADO. HERE
LIMÓN. HERE. LIMÓN. HERE.
MENGIBAR HERE. MENGIBAR. HERE.
RUBIO PRESENT. RUBIO. PRESENT.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. HERE. WIENER WE HAVE A
QUORUM. WE ALSO HAVE AN AUTHOR,
SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES. SAWYER. ITEM
NUMBER THREE, ASSEMBLY BILL
2064, COMMUNITY VIOLENCE
INTERDICTION GRANT PROGRAM.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MR. CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES. I'M HERE TO PRESENT
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMAN REGGIE
JONES-SAWYER, AB 2064, WHICH
WILL ESTABLISH THE COMMUNITY
VIOLENCE INTERDICTION GRANT
PROGRAM. THIS BILL IS AMONG THE
14 PRIORITY BILLS IDENTIFIED BY
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS AS PART OF THE
REPARATIONS BILL PACKAGE. THIS
BILL WOULD ADMINISTER WOULD BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
, AND WOULD REQUIRE FUNDING FOR
COMMUNITY DRIVEN SOLUTIONS TO
DECREASE VIOLENCE IN OUR SCHOOLS
AND NEIGHBORHOODS, AS OPPOSED TO
THE CONTINUATION OF
INCARCERATION. THE FUNDS WOULD
BE SECURED THROUGH AN
APPROPRIATION OF THE SAVINGS
FROM ANY FUTURE PRISON CLOSURE
WITHIN THE STATE. BY ALLOCATING
RESOURCES TO THESE PREVENTATIVE
INITIATIVES, WE REDUCE
INCARCERATION EVEN FURTHER AND
FOCUS ON FINDING SOLUTIONS TO
CRIME BEYOND THE INCARCERATION
OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE AND
UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS. AB 2064
ALLOWS FOR TRUE REHABILITATION
THROUGH PUTTING AN EMPHASIS ON
THE COMMUNITY AND THE VICTIMS
IMPACTED, GIVES THEM VOICE, AND
REDUCES MONETARY EXPENDITURES
ACCRUED ON IMPRISONMENT, WHICH
IS NOT BEEN SHOWN TO REDUCE
RECIDIVISM. I WANT TO THANK YOU,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, FOR YOUR
ATTENTION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE? DILLONLIAM. ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
CHILD AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. KELLY BROOKS, ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. SANDRA POOLE, ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY AND SUPPORT, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SEEING NONE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE. BRING IT BACK TO THE DESK.
COLLEAGUES. ANY QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS? IF NOT
SEEING NONE, SENATOR, YOU MAY
CLOSE. WELL, I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR. I VOTE IT'S BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR MENGIBAR. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATOR ROSS. AYE.
ROTH. AYE. WHEN? NO, WHEN? NO
GLAZER. GONZALEZ. GROVE HURTADO.
HURTADO. AYE. LIMÓN AYE. LIMÓN.
AYE. MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. RUBIO. AYE
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. WIENER
CURRENT. CURRENT VOTE IS 6 TO 1.
WE'LL HOLD THAT MATTER. OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LET'S NOW, JUST TO POINT
OUT TO THOSE WHO WEREN'T HERE,
TWO BILLS WERE PULLED FROM
TODAY'S AGENDA. ITEM NUMBER 12,
AB 2319. ASSEMBLYMEMBERS WILSON
AND WEBER AND ITEM NUMBER 18, AB
3218 ASSEMBLY MEMBER. WOULD WE
HAVE TEN BILLS ON OUR PROPOSED
CONSENT CALENDAR? ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB 1841 ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER, STUDENT SAFETY ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB 2161 ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA. THE EARLY
PSYCHOSIS INTERVENTION PLUS
PROGRAM ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
2237. SOME MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
CHILDREN AND YOUTH. ITEM NUMBER
NINE AB 20 703 ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
AGUIAR-CURRY FEDERALLY QUALIFIED
HEALTH CENTERS AND RURAL HEALTH
CLINICS, ITEM NUMBER 11, AB
2271. ASSEMBLY MEMBER ORTEGA
SAINT ROSE HOSPITAL, ITEM NUMBER
13, AB 2428 ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
CALDERON CALDERON, MEDI-CAL.
ITEM NUMBER 14. ASSEMBLY BILL
2549 ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER.
PATIENT VISITATION WITH
AMENDMENTS. ITEM NUMBER 15 AB
2550. ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL
BUSINESS ESTABLISHED ITS ITEM
NUMBER 16, AB 2599.
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE, WATER AND
ITEM NUMBER 19, AB 2859 ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JIM PATTERSON, EMERGENCY
MEDICAL TECHNICIANS PEER SUPPORT
WITH AMENDMENTS. IS THERE A
MOTION? MOVE IT! MOVED BY
SENATOR NGUYEN, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION, BY THE WAY, IS
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SENATOR
ROTH, A ROTH I WHEN I WHEN I
GLASER. GLASER I GONZALEZ.
GROVE. HURTADO HURTADO I LIMÓN I
LIMÓN I MENGIBAR. I MENGIBAR. I.
RUBIO I. RUBIO. I. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I
WIENER VOTE IS EIGHT ZERO WILL
HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. ITEM NUMBER TWO. AB
1843 ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ.
EMERGENCY AMBULANCE EMPLOYEES.
THE MOTION SOLICIT A MOTION. THE
MOTION IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. IS THERE A MOTION?
HAPPY TO MOVE IT. MOVED BY
SENATOR GLASER. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR ROTH. AYE ROTH I
WHEN I WHEN I GLASER. GLASER. I
GONZALEZ. GROVE HURTADO. HURTADO
I LIMÓN I LIMON I MENGIBAR I
MENGIBAR I RUBIO I RUBIO I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I WIENER VOTE IS EIGHT
ZERO WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. ITEM NUMBER FOUR
AB 2075. ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ
RESIDENT ACCESS PROTECTION ACT.
THE MOTION I'LL SOLICIT IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HUMAN SERVICES.
IS THERE A MOTION? Þ HURTADO.
SENATOR HURTADO MADE THE MOTION.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
ROSS I ROTH I WHEN I WHEN I.
GLASER. GLASER I GONZALEZ.
GROVE. HURTADO HURTADO I LIMÓN.
I LIMON. I MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR I
RUBIO. RUBIO. I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I
WIENER CUEVAS I DUNNO, I DUNNO.
OKAY, WHAT'S THE VOTE ON PHÐ.
OKAY AND WIENER IS HERE. WHAT'S
THE VOTE. SEVEN 7 TO 1. OKAY. TO
EVERY MEMBER MISSING PEOPLE
STILL, RIGHT? YEAH, YEAH. ROVERS
BILL CURRENT VOTE IS 7 TO 1.
WILL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS, NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER FIVE. AB 2132,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IS MOTION DO PASS AS
AMENDED. WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. IS THERE
A MOTION? GONZALEZ HAD SAID
GONZALEZ WANTED TO. WELL, SHE'S
GOT TO BE HERE, THOUGH SHE'S NOT
HERE. I'LL MOVE IT. SENATOR
NGUYEN MOVES IT. LET'S CALL THE
ROLL SENATOR ROTH I ROTH I WHEN
I, WHEN I GLASER. GLASER I
GONZALEZ. GROVE. HURTADO HURTADO
I LIMÓN LIMÓN I MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR I RUBIO. RUBIO I RUBIO.
I. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. I WIENER. I WIENER. I
VOTE IS NINE ZERO. WE'LL HOLD
THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. NEXT ITEM. ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AB 2339. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY MEDI-CAL.
TELEHEALTH. THE MOTION WILL BE
TO PASS AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. IS
THERE A MOTION SO MOVED? SENATOR
RUBIO MAKES THE MOTION. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR ROTH I
ROTH I WHEN. GLASER. GLASER I
GONZALEZ. GROVE. HURTADO I.
HURTADO I LIMÓN I LIMÓN I
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR I. RUBIO. I.
RUBIO I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WIENER
WIENER I. VOTE COUNT IS 8 TO 0
WILL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. NEXT ITEM. ITEM
NUMBER TEN AB 2258. SO MANY
MEMBERS OF BIR HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE COST SHARING. THE
MOTION, IF MADE, IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. IS
THERE A MOTION HURTADO BY
SENATOR HURTADO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR ROTH AYE. ROTH.
AYE. WHEN GLASER. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE.
HURTADO. HURTADO. AYE LIMÓN.
AYE. LIMÓN. AYE. MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR. AYE. RUBIO. AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. WIENER.
WIENER AYE. VOTE COUNT IS NINE
ZERO. WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER 17. AB 2749.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, WOOD,
CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFIT
EXCHANGE. THE MOTION IS MADE DO,
PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. IS
THERE A MOTION SO MOVED BY
SENATOR GLAZER PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR ROTH. ROTH. AYE
WHEN? GLASER. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
HURTADO. HURTADO. AYE. LIMÓN
LIMON. AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE
MENGIBAR. AYE. RUBIO. RUBIO.
AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. WIENER
WIENER. AYE. VOTE COUNT IS NINE
ZERO. WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. AND THAT
CONCLUDES THE LIST. WE CAN GET.
WE COULD GET WIENER AND GONZALEZ
ON THE CONSENT AND GLAZER 16 ON
ONE, TWO, THREE MEMBERS NEXT
WEEK. WHICH ONES DO WE HAVE TO
CALL IF WE CAN ALL FIGURE OUT
HOW TO GET EITHER ONE? THURSDAY
I THOUGHT THAT WAS A WEEK AFTER.
OH YEAH, IT'S NOT NEXT WEEK. SO.
LET'S OPEN THE ROLL. WE'RE GOING
TO START FIRST ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
WEREN'T HERE, THE CONSENT
CALENDAR, YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS,
THE WE HAVE A REQUEST. YES THE
MOTION WAS MADE BY SENATOR
NGUYEN. THE VOTE COUNT ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS 8 TO 0.
PLEASE THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. SENATOR
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE
WIENER. WIENER. AYE. ON THE
FLOOR. CURRENT VOTE IS TEN ZERO.
WE'LL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. OUR NEXT ITEM,
ITEM NUMBER TWO, AB 1843,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ.
EMERGENCY AMBULANCE EMPLOYEES.
THE MOTION WAS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. CURRENT
VOTE COUNT IS 8 TO 0. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
. SENATOR GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE WIENER. WIENER. AYE
CURRENT VOTE TEN ZERO WILL HOLD
THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. NEXT, NEXT ITEM. ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB 2006 FOR SOME
MEMBER. JONES. SAWYER. COMMUNITY
VIOLENCE INTERDICTION GRANT
PROGRAM. MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY. CURRENT VOTE SIX ONE.
CHAIR VOTING AYE. PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL. SENATOR GLAZER.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. WIENER
AYE. WIENER. AYE. CURRENT VOTE.
COUNT 9 TO 1 WILL HOLD THE ROW
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. NEXT
ITEM, ITEM NUMBER FOUR. AB 2075.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ALVAREZ.
RESIDENT. ACCESS PROTECTION ACT
MOTION DO PASS AS AMENDED, AND
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON HUMAN
SERVICES. CURRENT VOTE 7 TO 1
CHAIR. VOTING AYE. PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE. SENATOR GONZALEZ.
GROVE WIENER. CURRENT VOTE SEVEN
ONE WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. NEXT ITEM. ITEM
NUMBER FIVE IS AB 2132. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOWE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. MOTION DO PASS AS
AMENDED AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. CURRENT
VOTE NINE ZERO CHAIR VOTING AYE.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. SEN.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE.
CURRENT VOTE TEN ZERO WILL HOLD
THE ROW OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
NEXT ITEM. ITEM NUMBER EIGHT. AB
2339. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY. MEDICAL TELEHEALTH
MOVED BY SENATOR RUBIO. MOTION
TO PASS AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT ZERO. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE. SENATOR NGUYEN. GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. CURRENT
VOTE NINE ZERO. HOLD ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. NEXT ITEM.
ITEM NUMBER TEN. AB 2258
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S OF BR. HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE. COST SHARING
MOVED BY SENATOR HURTADO. MOTION
TO PASS, AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE NINE ZERO. CHAIR.
VOTING AYE. PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL. SENATOR NGUYEN GROVE,
CURRENT VOTE. NINE ZERO WILL
HOLD A ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. NEXT ITEM. ITEM NUMBER
17 AB 2749. ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
WOOD, CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFIT
EXCHANGE. MOTION DO PASS AND
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATION. MOVED BY SENATOR
GLAZER. CURRENT VOTE NINE ZERO.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. SENATOR
NGUYEN GROVE KHN VOTE NINE ZERO
WILL HOLD THE ROLL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THAT IS IT ON THIS
GO ROUND. SHE'S DONE PRESENTING
AND SHE SHOULD BE HERE ANY
SECOND. OKAY, PERFECT. OKAY.
OKAY. GREAT. YES. GROVE SHOULD
BE HERE ANY MINUTE.
ARE. YOU CAN FINISH NOW, SIR.
YOU WAITED ON ME FOR TWO HOURS.
THAT'S OKAY. LET'S OPEN THE
ROLL. WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. DO I NEED
SENATOR? DO I NEED TO READ OFF
THE BILLS FOR YOU FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR? NO, THANK YOU,
SIR. OKAY CONSENT CALENDAR MOVED
BY SENATOR NGUYEN, THE MOTION DO
PASS REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION TO SEND THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. CURRENT VOTE
IS TEN ZERO. CHAIR. VOTING AYE.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. SEN.
GROVE. GROVE I VOTE IS 11 ZERO.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT.
NEXT ITEM, ITEM NUMBER TWO. AB
1843. ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ.
EMERGENCY AMBULANCE EMPLOYEE.
EMPLOYEES. THE MOTION WAS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED. REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY MADE BY
SENATOR GLAZER. CURRENT VOTE TEN
ZERO CHAIR. VOTING AYE. PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL. SENATOR GROVE.
GROVE I VOTE 11 ZERO. THAT BILL
IS OUT. NEXT ITEM, ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB 2064 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER. COMMUNITY VIOLENCE
INTERDICTION GRANT PROGRAM.
SENATOR. MEN MADE THE MOTION.
SENATOR. MEN. SENATE. SENATOR
MENGIBAR MADE THE MOTION TO
PASS. WE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON PUBLIC SAFETY. CURRENT VOTE 9
TO 1. CHAIR VOTING AYE. PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL. SENATOR GROVE.
NO. GROVE. NO. VOTE. COUNT IS 9
TO 2. THAT BILL IS OUT. NEXT
ITEM, ITEM NUMBER FOUR, AB 2075.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ.
RESIDENT ACCESS PROTECTION ACT.
MOTION BY SENATOR TARLOW DO
PASSES AMENDED AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HUMAN SERVICES.
CURRENT VOTE 7 TO 1 CHAIR.
VOTING AYE. PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
. SENATOR GONZALEZ GROVE. Ã.
GROVE. AYE. WIENER CURRENT VOTE
COUNT 8 TO 1. THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB 2132.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWE, HEALTH
CARE SERVICES MOTION BY SENATOR
NGUYEN DO PASS AS AMENDED AND RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. CURRENT VOTE TEN ZERO
CHAIR VOTING AYE. PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL. SENATOR. GROVE. GROVE.
AYE VOTE COUNT 11 TO 0. THAT
MATTER IS OUT. NEXT ITEM, ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT. AB 2339. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY MEDICAL
TELEHEALTH MOTION BY SENATOR
RUBIO DO PASS AND BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 9 TO 0. PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL. CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATOR NGUYEN GROVE, CURRENT
VOTE COUNT NINE ZERO. THAT
MATTER IS OUT. NEXT ITEM. ITEM
NUMBER TEN AB 2258. BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ZUBER. HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. COST SHARING. THE
MOTION BY SENATOR HURTADO DO
PASS, AS AMENDED AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE COUNT NINE ZERO.
CHAIR VOTING AYE. PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL. SENATOR NGUYEN GROVE,
CURRENT VOTE NINE ZERO. THAT
MATTER IS OUT AT. NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER 17 AB 2749 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, WOOD CALIFORNIA
HEALTH BENEFIT EXCHANGE. MOTION
BY SENATOR GLAZER DO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. VOTE COUNT IS
NINE ZERO. CHAIR VOTING AYE.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. SENATOR
NGUYEN GROVE, VOTE COUNT IS NINE
ZERO. THAT MATTER IS OUT AND
THAT CONCLUDES THE AGENDA FOR
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE FOR TODAY.
WE ARE ADJOURNED.